WELCOME TO OUR SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
PLEASE TURN OFF ALL YOUR CELL
PHONE SO --
AND TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OUTSIDE IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
SO WE CAN HEAR OUR TESTIMONY --
AND WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL HEARING --
WE HAD AN OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
THE DMV LAST NOVEMBER.
AT THAT TIME WE FOUND THAT THE
CUSTOMER WAIT TIMES HAD DECLINED.
TO OF FAIRLY ACCEPTABLE LEVELS
AND THAT THE DMV HAD MET ITS OWN
TARGETS REDUCING THOSE TIMES.
NOW SAYS SAID OF COURSE WE'VE
HAD A NEW ADMINISTRATION ROOM
NEW GOVERNOR [inaudible]
AND HAVE TO AND THEY HAVE TAKEN
ACTIONS ON THEIR OWN.
INCLUDING BRING IN A NEW DMV
DIRECTOR STASHING A STRIKE TEAM.
TO OVERSEE THE JOURNAL
PERFORMANCE REVIEW --
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT THE SUBJECT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES.
AND WE'RE INTERESTED IN HEARING
ABOUT THOSE ACTIVITIES SO --
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
STRIKE TEAM TODAY UNDERSTATE THE
FINAL REPORT ISN'T --
YEAH COMPLETE THEY'RE STILL --
PULLING IT TOGETHER BUT WE WANT
TO HEAR PROGRESS HERE TODAY WE
ALSO WANT UNDERSTAND HOW.
THE DMV IS SERVING THEIR
CUSTOMERS SENSOR OUR LAST
HEARING ON THE SUBJECT AND AND
WE'RE INTERESTED IN --
OPINION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST.
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW THEY MIGHT.
BE ABLE TO HELP US ENSURE DMV
PROVIDES A LEVEL SERVICE THAT
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT.
AND AT SOME POINT --
WE UNDERSTAND THAT --
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WERE
COMPLETED IT'S AUDIT STARTED
DIRECTION GOVERNOR OF FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
ABOUT THAT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AS WELL.
AND UNDERLYING ALL THIS NEED --
THAT WE HAVE. TO REVIEW THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE DMV I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE PUBLIC.
AND OTHERS ABOUT HOW WE CAN HELP.
OUR DMV DO A BETTER JOB.
AND IN WE'VE INTERVIEWS --
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP WITH
ANY STATUTORY DIRECTION THAT WE
CAN COME UP WITH IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND MIGHT BE NECESSARY --
WE WE WANT TO ASK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE HAVE ANY I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE COMMENTS --
OFFERS TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE.
ON THIS HEARING --
SIR WHAT KOWSKI BOB THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE BUDGET SUB TO
WHICH HAS --
JURISDICTION OVER DMV WILL NOT
HAVE THEIR HEARING ON THE BUDGET
THE GOVERNOR'S --
BUT YOU TOLL --
NEXT MONTH I THINK ONE THE
CONCERNS ONLY THE REQUEST BUT
BUT THE REAL ID --
THERE ARE STAFF REPORT TALKS
ABOUT -- THE
FIRST HALF OF THIS FISCAL YEAR
HAVING ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION REAL IDEAS ISSUE WHICH
IS.
ABOUT 60% OF WHAT THEY THOUGHT
OR 70% OF WHAT THEY THOUGHT AND
WE STILL HAVE THESE LONG LINES
AND THAT THE PROBLEM SO IF WE
GET UP TO THE LEVEL THAT WE
ANTICIPATE OR EXCEED THAT.
HOW HOW THAT'S GOING TO IMPACT
EACH LOCATION THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND IN THE BUDGET
REQUEST SO I'M TRYING?
TO IT WILL BE KEENLY WATCHING
WHAT THE INFORMATION COMES IN IS
IS HOW MANY PEOPLE ACTUALLY
SHOWING UP AND HOW THAT THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE WEIGHTS
AND THE OPERATION WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON AND SEE WHAT KIND OF
WAVE HOW BIG THE THE ALLIED AWAY
WILL BE IT'LL BE.
MID SIZE LARGE WILL FIND OUT --
HOPEFULLY IN THIS HEARING THEY
CAN GET SOME ANSWERS --
WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A GUEST HERE --
FROM THE ASSEMBLY --
CHAIR --
JOINT LEGISLATIVE RUDY SALAS AND
RUDY --
WELCOME.
AND RUDY HAS SOME COMECEI LIKE
TO MAKE GREAT ROOM.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL AND THINK
SENATE BILL FOR HAVING ME AT%
TODAY'S HEARING YOU KNOW AS
CHAIR OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE.
THAT'S CRITICAL THAT WE ENSURE
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN ALL
GOVERNMENTS --
THE ONGOING ISSUES THAT THE ENVY
OF HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
INCREASED.
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY LIKE TO THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME --
FORCE COMMITMENT TO MODERNIZING
AND OVERHAULING THE DMV THROUGH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE STRIKE
TEAMS WHICH I KNOW WILL CURE
FROM SHORTLY --
THAT ADDRESS MANY OF THE ISSUES
IN FRUSTRATION THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING WITH THE MV --
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE --
I'M LOOKING FOR TO TODAY'S
HEARING AND GETTING SOME ANSWERS
I KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN --
REQUESTS AT THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE. TO
TO HAVE AN AUDIT OF DMV.
THAT THROUGH ITS MANY FACTIONS
I'M I'M OPEN TO LEARN A LOT HERE
TODAY AND THANK YOU SENATOR BILL
FOR FOR HAVING ME FOR ****.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OTHER OTHER OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
ANY COMMENTS IF NOT WE'LL GET
OUR HEARING --
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR ARE --
GUESTS TO WE'RE GONNA HAVE OUR
SECRETARY.
OF THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
COMMITTEE AND SHE'S HERE.
YEAH NOW SHE'S GOT A LOT OF JOBS
SO WE'RE GOING TO LET HER GO
THROUGH FIRST --
MERRY BILL ABOUT YOUR AND SHE'S --
KIND OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY SHE'S ALSO
WORKING ON THE THE CENSUS TODAY
SO WE'RE GONNA LET HER GO FIRST
AND THEN GO BACK TO WORK ON THAT
OTHER REPORT PROJECTS SO WELCOME.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
MADAM SECRETARY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE --
YOUR INDULGENCE TO ALLOWING ME
TO TESTIFY HERE BEFORE YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE --
BECAUSE I AM INDEED CHAIR IN THE
CAL IT'S COMMITTEE AND IT TOOK A
LITTLE BREAK FOR LUNCH SO
HOPEFULLY.
I'LL BE BACK WITH THEM IN GOOD
TIME TO FINISH UP.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SENATORS AND MEMBERS SALAS --
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY AND FOR ACCOMMODATING
AGAIN MY SCHEDULE.
AS YOU KNOW IN EARLY JANUARY
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM APPOINTED
ME TO LEAD.
A DMB STRIKE TEAM THE GOAL OF
WHICH WAS TO REINVENT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES.
THE STRIKE TEAM WAS GIVEN SIX
MONTHS TO BEGIN.
THIS WORK AND WHILE WE ALL KNOW
THE SIGNIFICANT CHANGE WILL TAKE
LONGER I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT THE STRIKE TEAM IS DONE IN
ITS FIRST WEEKS.
AND WHERE WE ARE HEADED.
I BELIEVE THAT AT THE END OF SIX
MONTHS THE DMB WILL BE ON A PATH
OF SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AND INDEED
REINVENTION.
FIRST LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
THE MISSION OF THE STRIKE TEAM
IS WE WANT TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF CREATING THE DMV OF THE
FUTURE.
THE STRIKE TEAMS OBJECTIVE IS TO
BEGIN THE WORK OF SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE AND REINVENTION FOR THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC FACING STATE
AGENCY.
IN ORDER TO CREATE THE DMV OF
THE FUTURE THE STRIKE TEAM IS
ALREADY MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
DELIVERING SERVICES TO PEOPLE IN
THE WAY THEY WANT THEM.
EASY AFFECTIVE AND ACCESSIBLE.
WE ALL KNOW THE DMB IS GRAPPLING
WITH TO SIGNIFICANT ISSUES REAL
ID AND MOTOR VOTER.
REAL ID HAS A FAST APPROACHING
DEADLINE EVERY CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEEDS TO FLY OR ENTER A SECURE
FEDERAL FACILITY OR MILITARY
BASE.
AND DOES NOT HAVE A VALID
PASSPORT MUST HAVE A REAL ID BY
OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY GETTING A REAL ID
REQUIRES A VISIT TO A DMV FIELD
OFFICE AND WHILE THERE'S NO WAY
AROUND THAT VISIT WE ARE ALREADY
WORKING ON SEVERAL EFFORTS WHICH
I WILL DESCRIBE IN MORE DETAIL
IN A MOMENT. TO GET AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO KNEW OR THE
DEADLINE WITHOUT INCREASING
FIELD OFFICE WAIT TIMES.
MOTOR VOTER IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE WE BELIEVE BETTER OUTCOMES
ARE WITHIN REACH AS THE DMB
IMPROVES ITS TRAINING CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND TECHNOLOGY.
AS WITH ANYTHING ONE CHANGE IS
NOT A SILVER BULLET THERE NEEDS
TO ME MANY SILVER POINTS THE
STRIKE TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING ON
A SERIES OF ACTIONS TOGETHER.
I BELIEVE WHICH WILL BRING NEW
WAYS OF OPERATING BOTH
INTERNALLY AND EXTERNALLY TO THE
DMV.
THESE MAY START WITH ONE FOCUS
BUT WILL THEN BE ABLE TO BE
CARRIED THROUGH ALL CORNERS OF
THE ORGANIZATION.
THE FIRST ACTION OF THE STRIKE
TEAM WAS TO MEET WITH SENIOR
LEADERS OF THE DMV TO LEARN
ABOUT THEIR WORK AND THEIR
CHALLENGES.
WE ALSO CREATED AN ONLINE INTAKE
FORM.
EXCUSE ME ON THE GOV UPS WEBSITE
FOR DIEM BE EMPLOYEES AND ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC TO AT THEIR
DISCRETION PROVIDE INPUT AND
SHARE IDEAS WITH THE STRIKE TEAM.
WE'VE BEEN GATHERING THAT
INFORMATION AND PASSING ON TO
THE DMV WHERE APPROPRIATE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS.
THE STRIKE TEAM ALSO REVIEWED
THE DEPARTMENT'S IT CAPACITY TO
ASSESS THE READINESS OF THE
DMV'S ENVIRONMENT TO
SUCCESSFULLY MODERNIZE THEIR
DELIVERY OF SERVICES.
THE STRIKE TEAM IS STARTING THE
PROCESS OF ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT TO BUILD A CULTURE OF
EMPLOYEE EMPOWERED CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
THIS WILL INCLUDE BUILDING THE
IT CAPACITY WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
HUMAN AND TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOCUSED ON
SERVICE DELIVERY.
SECURITY AND RELIABILITY.
WE WERE ALSO CONFRONTED WITH
SEVERAL VACANCIES AND I'M
PLEASED THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOME
APPOINTED KATHLEEN WEB AS THE
ACTING DIRECTOR YOU WILL HEAR
FROM HER SHORTLY.
KATHLEEN WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT AT
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY AND
HAS A RICH BACKGROUND IN RISK
MANAGEMENT LEAN PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT AND ORGANIZATIONAL
MANAGEMENT.
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR WHAT
THE STRIKE TEAM THAT THE STRIKE
TEAM IS ACTION ORIENTED WE HAVE
HAD MANY MEETINGS WITH
INTERESTED PARTIES DONE
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH AND ARE NOW
CREATING RECOMMENDED NEXT STEPS.
I'M GONNA START WITH CREDIT
CARDS IN THE FIELD OFFICES
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR SPOKE
ABOUT IN HIS BUDGET ROLLOUT.
I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR NO SENSE THAT IN AN ERA
WHERE I CAN USE MY CREDIT CARD.
AT A GIRL SCOUT COOKIE BOOTH BUT
I CAN'T USE IT A DMV FIELD
OFFICE. TO EXPLORE THIS ISSUE
WE'VE HAD MANY MEETINGS BOTH
WITH OUTSIDE ENTITIES AND WITH
THE DMV TEAM AND BELIEVE THE
ISSUES THAT PREVIOUSLY SEEMED TO
BLOCK THIS ACTION.
ARE NOT OBSTACLES THAT WE CAN'T
OVERCOME WE ARE LOOKING ON A
PATH WE ARE WORKING ON A PATH
FORWARD AND EXPECT THE
GOVERNOR'S CHARGE.
OF HAVING A CREDIT CARD OR
CREDIT CARD USE IN THE FIELD
OFFICES BY THE END OF THE YEAR
TO BE REALIZED. ONE OF OUR KEY
EFFORTS IS TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
THE FIELD OFFICES IF THEY DON'T
NEED TO BE THERE.
THAT MEANS INCREASING THE
ABILITY TO CONDUCT A DMB
BUSINESS AT OTHER LOCATIONS
WHETHER IT IS ONLINE OR AT A
KIOSK OR WITH A BUSINESS PARTNER.
WE KNOW IN TODAY'S WORLD THE
FIRST PLACE PEOPLE GO TO GET
INFORMATION IS THE INTERNET.
THAT IS WHY WE WANT TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE DMV WEBSITE
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE CAN EASILY
FIND THE INFORMATION THEY NEED.
SOME IMPROVEMENTS WERE MADE LAST
SUMMER BUT THERE'S MUCH MORE
WORK TO BE DONE WE LEARNED THAT
THE DMV WEBSITE HAS ELEVEN
THOUSAND PAGES.
THAT'S HARDLY USER FRIENDLY.
A FULL WEBSITE OVER OVER HALL
WILL TAKE TIME BUT WE ARE
WORKING ON SHORT SHORT TERM
IMPROVEMENTS.
IF YOU CAN'T FIND WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR ON A WEBSITE THE
NEXT STEP IS YOU PICK UP THE
PHONE.
WELL THAT EXPERIENCE HAS ALSO
BEEN FRUSTRATING TO DMB
CUSTOMERS THE STRIKE TEAM
BROUGHT IN THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO DO A THOROUGH REVIEW OF
DMV'S CALL CENTER PRACTICES.
AND SHARED BEST PRACTICES FTD
STAFF.
HAVE YOU EVALUATED THE PROCESSES
OF THE SACRAMENTO'S CALL CENTER
AND HAD HAVE VISITS SCHEDULED
THIS MONTH TO THE RIVER SIDE IN
THE FRESNO FACILITIES.
THESE REVIEW AND SHARED --
SEIZURES WILL HELP THE DMV
IMPROVE THEIR OPERATIONS AND
LOWER HOLD TIMES ADDITIONALLY WE
HOPE TO ADD MORE CAPABILITIES
SUCH AS CHAT BOTS LIVE CHAT.
AS WELL AS THE ABILITY TO
PROCESS MORE RE TREAT ROUTINE
TRANSACTIONS BY THE TELEPHONE
TREND --
TECHNICIANS.
IN ADDITION WE ARE PLANNING TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF SELF
SERVICE TERMINALS OR KIOSKS
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND ADDING NEW SERVICES TO THOSE
KIOSKS THE FIRST FIX IS TO ADD
MORE LANGUAGES TO THE KIOSK
WHICH WAS PLANNED PREVIOUSLY --
TO THE STRIKE TEAM WE ALSO HOPE
TO ADD A HUNDRED SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS AT KEY LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BY THIS
SUMMER AND ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED
BY THE END OF THE YEAR
[inaudible]
CURRENTLY KIOSKS PROCESS VEHICLE
REGISTRATION RENEWALS BUT WE
HAVE LEARNED THAT THEY DOOM MANY
MORE FUNCTIONS AND OTHER STATES
FOR EXAMPLE THE ABILITY.
OF CHAOS TO ISSUE A REPLACEMENT
DRIVER'S LICENSE WOULD SAVE
THOUSANDS OF VISITS. TO THE
FIELD OFFICES AS OVER A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO CALIFORNIANS
LOSE THEIR LICENSES ANNUALLY AND
HAVE TO GO INTO A FIELD OFFICE.
TO HAVE A REPLACEMENT AS I HAVE
SAID ONE OF OUR MAIN GOALS IS TO
REDUCE AVOIDABLE VISITS TO THE
FIELD OFFICE AS PART OF THE
STRATEGY THE STRIKE TEAM IS
WORKING WITH A PILOT TO BRING
THE DMV TO MAJOR COMPANIES.
IN THE STATE IN ORDER TO HELP
THEIR EMPLOYEES GET A REAL ID
THIS POP UP DMV IDEA IS DESIGNED
TO HELP OUR STATE'S BUSINESS
TRAVELERS.
WITH ADVANCE NOTICE AND
COORDINATION EMPLOYERS COULD
PREPARE EMPLOYEES TO PULL
TOGETHER REQUIRED DOCUMENTS AND
BRING THEM TO WORK ON A
DESIGNATED DAY ENABLING THEM
PLACE TO COMPLETE THE ENTIRE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
AT THEIR WORK LOCATION WE HAVE
THE FIRST PILOT SCHEDULED FOR
THE FIRST WEEK IN APRIL AND IF
IT IS SUCCESSFUL WE HOPE TO HAVE
MANY MORE THAT ARE LARGE
CORPORATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO EXAMINE THE
COMMUNICATIONS AROUND RELY DE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THOSE COMING
TO FIELD OFFICES FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE DOCUMENTATION
THAT THEY NEED AND THAT EVERYONE
WHO FILES KNOWS THAT.
THEY SHOULD ANY WHEN THAT FLIES
KNOWS.
TWENTY TWENTY IF THEY DO NOT
HAVE A VALID PASSPORT.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'RE ROLLING OUT IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCES WITH THE DMV BUT AS
I SAID AT THE BEGINNING.
ON OF OUR OF OUR TESTIMONY OUR
GOAL IS NOT TO IMPROVE WAIT
TIMES AND MOVE ON WE BELIEVE
THERE MUST BE A COMPREHENSIVE
CHANGE IN HOW DMB WORKS.
THE STRIKE TEAM IS STARTING WITH
PROCESSES SURROUNDING REAL ID
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT THESE
CONVENTICLES BANDED TO OTHER KEY
DMV FUNCTIONS.
AT THE STRIKE TEAMS REQUEST THE
DMV HAS ISSUED A REQUEST FOR
OFFER OUR F. O. FOR CONSULTING
SERVICES WITH THE GOAL OF
STREAMLINING THE ISSUANCE OF
RELY DIS.
BASED ON USER RESEARCH THE
CONSULTANT WILL UNDERTAKE A
SERIES OF DESIGNS SPRINTS
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
COMMUNICATIONS AROUND REAL ID
IMPROVING TRAINING TO PREPARE
FIELD OFFICE TECHNICIANS AND
DEVELOPING BETTER FIELD CUSTOMER
SERVICE FLOW.
IN EACH SPRINT THE CONSULTANT
WILL ASSESS THE CURRENT STATE
PRIORITIZE IMPROVEMENT IDEAS
THAN PLAN AND PROTOTYPE NEW
APPROACHES FOR IMPROVED RESULTS
THE CONSULTANT WORKING WITH DIEM
THE STAFF WILL INTEGRATE
LEARNINGS FROM THE SPRINTS.
INTO A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
FOR MEETING GREATER DEMAND FOR
REAL ID'S WITHOUT INCREASING
WAIT TIMES.
THIS FIVE MONTH CONTRACT IS
EXPECTED TO BEGIN THIS MONTH AND
WE EXPECT IT TO DELIVER RESULTS
STARTING IN JUNE.
I HOPE THAT THIS IS GIVING YOU
AN IDEA OF THE WORK THE STRIKE
TEAM HAS UNDERTAKEN WELL WE ARE
LESS THAN TEN WEEKS IN.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS PROGRESS
AND I AND WE ARE ON A PATH TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
AND BEGIN THE WORK.
OF INDEED THE DMV OF THE FUTURE
AND OF COURSE MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M VERY HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU AND THE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU WE HADN'T A FEW
MEMBERS --
ARRIVE.
THANK YOU.
FOR SPENDING SOMETIME I I WHEN --
WE LOOK AT THE DMV AND COMPARES
TO OTHER STATES.
WE SEE THAT OTHER STATES ARE
DOING THINGS THAT WE DON'T DO.
AS BECAUSE IT'S NEVER BEEN --
LOOK THERE ARE IN THE WAY WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT WHAT YOU'RE
STRIKE TEAM.
SO.
I TAKE THE JOB.
WHEN I LOOK AT OTHER STATES I
SEE THINGS LIKE MULTI YEAR
REGISTRATION?
OF REGISTRATION AT THE SMOG
CHECK LOCATIONS SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE KEYS THE SHOES SOCKS AT
WHATEVER THE SCHOOLS
UNIVERSITIES.
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES ARE
YOU ARE YOU --
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT THE BIGGER?
YOU KNOW LIKE WE DON'T HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL HERE IN SOME
CASES -- ON
TECHNOLOGY OR HOW DO YOU SAY --
GOOD IDEAS OTHER STATES ARE
USING.
EFFECTIVE IDEAS SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE IS LOOKING
PROMISING THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
THE CONSOLE LOOK INTO.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE --
LOOKED EXTENSIVELY IN MANY
STATES THERE SOME GREAT EXAMPLES
INDIANA IS ONE NEW YORK IS ONE
HAWAII COLORADO FLORIDA.
AND THE A LOT INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH.
MANY OF THE SAME VENDORS THAT
SERVICE CALIFORNIA DMV ALSO
PROVIDES SERVICES TO THOSE DMV'S
I'LL TAKE AS AN EXAMPLE THE
KIOSK VENDOR --
I TI THEY SERVICE --
INDIANA HAWAIIAN COLORADO SO
WE'VE MET WITH THEM.
SEVERAL TIMES AND AND HAVE JUST
OFFER KNOWING WHAT THEY OFFER BY
GOING ON THE WEBSITE TO THE OF
THE STATE'S AND INDEED WE HAVE
EVEN I'VE EVEN BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH --
INDIANA --
AND IT THERE WE ARE
INVESTIGATING AND CERTAINLY AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY WILL --
HOPEFULLY HAVE EIGHT EXTENSIVE
MORE SERVICES AT ON OUR CHAOS
JUST AS THEY DO AN INDIAN AND
THE OTHER STATES.
YOU'RE RIGHT IN IN INDIANA THEY
MOVED --
VEHICLE REGISTRATION OUT OF
THEIR FIELD OFFICES QUITE
SOMETIME AGO AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT SOME AT
SOME OF THOSE THINGS ARE NOT
STRIKING.
THEIR LONGER TERM IN OPERATIONAL
CHANGES.
BUT IF WE COULD AS I MENTIONED
IF WE COULD JUST HAVE A
REPLACEMENT OF DRIVER'S LICENSES
DONE THROUGH THE KIOSK --
ONLINE WHICH THEY DO IN OTHER
STATES THAT WOULD KEEP A MILLION --
FOLKS OUT OF THE DMV FIELD
OFFICES ANNUALLY.
SO THERE THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
THAT STATES ARE DOING WITH REAL
ID TO I WILL SAY MANY ARE
STRUGGLING ARE SEEN CHALLENGES
AS WE ARE OUR VOLUME OF COURSE
IS MUCH LARGER THAN MOST STATES.
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY LEARN FROM
SOME OF THE THINGS AND HAVE --
THAT THEY'VE DONE IN THE AREAS
OF MARKETING AND COMMUNICATING
MORE THOROUGHLY SOMERS LAST LAST
FALL I BROUGHT UP THE MALL TO
YOUR REGISTRATION --
I I BROUGHT IT UP AGAIN TODAY
HOUSE THAT BEING LOOKED ON SIR
I'M GOING TO ASK THAT --
THE ACTING DIRECTOR KATHLEEN WEB
ADDRESS.
AGAIN THAT'S MORE OF I THINK AN
OPERATIONAL ISSUE --
BUT CERTAINLY THAT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT OKAY --
WE ALSO WE ALSO --
FIND THAT --
SOME OF OUR TECHNOLOGY --
LIKE IF YOU LOOK AT THE SHORT
TERM O SAYS YOU CAN DO BUT
REALLY LONG TERM THE TECHNOLOGY
IS PRETTY ANTIQUATED THE DMV --
CAN YOU GIVE US SORT OF OVERVIEW
OF HOW WE CAN HAVE A CUSTOMER
FRIENDLY TECHNOLOGY.
AND WHAT'S WHAT'S YOUR VISION.
TO GO LONG TERM SAY WE'RE
WORKING ON A FIVE YEAR TIME
CYCLE -- TO
GETTING PASTOR REAL ID PERIOD
AND RUNNING --
DESERTION TEAM THANK YOU THE
STRIKE TEAM --
UNDERTOOK A COMPLETE PORTFOLIO
REVIEW OF THE I. T. PROCESSES AT
DMV CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY.
AND IN THAT WE LEARNED THAT AS
YOU WELL KNOW --
THERE IS INSTABILITY --
AND IN IN THE IN THE STACK IF
YOU WILL FROM THE DMV A DATABASE
THROUGH AN UP TO THE FRONT
INTERIOR OF TECHNOLOGY AND THAT
STACK I NEEDS TO BE STABILIZED.
AND WE WILL BE UNDERTAKING --
IMMEDIATELY --
THE THE MIDDLE TIER IF I MAY
DESCRIBE IT THAT WAY IN
PARTICULAR SOME OF THE
PROPRIETARY.
NATURE OF OF THE CODE WORK THIS --
EXISTED OVER THE YEARS NEEDS TO
BE STABILIZED IMMEDIATELY AND
THE STRIKE TEAM --
WORKING WITH THIS CD T. N. DMV
WILL BE UNDERTAKING THAT RIGHT
AWAY SO THEN YOU CAN.
LOOK AT MORE MODERNIZING OF
TECHNOLOGY PROCESSES BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
THAT I THINK WAS A STUMBLING
BLOCK FOR A LONG TIME AT THE DMV.
FOR CREDIT CARD USE IN THE FIELD
OFFICES.
WAS ON SOME CONCERN ABOUT THE
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN THE FIELD
OFFICES AND HEADQUARTERS AS WELL
AS WHETHER OR NOT THE I. T.
SYSTEMS COULD.
PROPERLY DO RECONCILIATION IN
REAL TIME OR EVEN ONCE IN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS MOST OF THAT KIND OF
WORK TODAY IS DONE MY CARD
PROCESSING COMPANIES.
SO IF WE CAN AND I HAVE MET.
WITH ALMOST ALL OF CAN ASSURE
YOU -- IF WE
CAN OFF LOAD THAT RISK IF YOU
WILL AS MAJOR RETAILERS DUE. TO
THE CARD PROCESS TRULY ARE GOING
THROUGH A REVOLUTION OF
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THEIR ADOPTING EVERY
DAY.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SQUARE YOU
HAVE SO MANY CUTTING EDGE --
COMPANIES THAT EXISTS THAT CAN
TAKE THE CONNECTIVITY ISSUES AND
THE RECONCILIATION ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT OF A
STUMBLING BLOCK FOR DMV I THINK
WE CAN.
OFF LOAD THAT RISK TO THE CARD
PROCESSING COMPANIES.
THE AND WE'RE REALLY WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW THE KIND OF THINGS --
YOU MIGHT HAVE A GIRL SCOUT ON
YOUR STRIKE TEAM.
IT'S LIKE THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
IDEA I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THERE'S NO KNOWS NO AGE RULE
RIGHT GIRL SCOUT LEADER YEAH
WELL THERE WE GO WE GOT TO HAVE --
WE'LL GET SOME OF THE YOUNGER
PEOPLE THEY PROBABLY WOULD KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS --
AND HUESO SO I I TAKE --
OF ONE OF ONE OF THE HERE IS THE
LEGISLATURE.
PAYS A LOT ATTENTION TO ON ON
OUR SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC.
IS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE --
WITH LANGUAGE ISSUES OR
DISABILITIES OR ARE ELDERLY --
ARE TREATED --
WELL [inaudible]
AND PROBABLY MORE THAN WELL WE
WANT TO TREAT THEM WITH EXTRA
RESPECT.
AND I I THINK THE STRIKE TEAM
SHOULD LOOK AT HOW WE PROVIDE
SERVICES BETTER FOR THOSE.
THOSE GROUPS OF PEOPLE --
HER THAT HAVE OUR LANGUAGE
ISSUES SO.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT GOING TO
THE COMPANY'S --
TO DO THE REGISTRATION YOU CAN
PROBABLY LOOK AT SOME KIND OF
WAY OF GOING TO THE SENIOR
CENTERS.
OF WHERE THE SENIORS ARE SERIF
THERE'S SENIOR HOUSING --
PROGRAMS.
FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DISABILITIES THAT WANT TO TRAVEL --
AND ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
THAT ARE ABLE TO FUNCTION IN
TERMS OF PROCESSING.
OF THESE APPLICATIONS AND
PROCESSES WITHOUT SOME
ASSISTANCE SO.
I THINK -- I
THINK DOES.
I ALWAYS HAVE TO BRING THAT UP
IT'S KIND OF MY A YOU KNOW
TWELVE YEARS AS A THIRTEEN YEARS
I'VE BEEN --
OF I CONSERVE BEEN VERY
CONSISTENT.
IN RAISING THE ISSUE FOR THE
DISABLED.
ABOUT TREATMENT BY THE
GOVERNMENTAL SERVICES WITH A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
ISSUES SO I I APPRECIATE YOU
BROUGHT IT UP AGAIN TODAY THERE
ARE CONTINUE TO BRING IT UP AS
LONG AS I AM --
LEGISLATOR I I THINK THAT --
I THINK THAT --
THERE'S OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE THE DMV DOES --
I FOUND OUT.
I KNOW THE MEMBERS KNOW THIS BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF PARTS OF THE
PENAL CODE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT ACTUALLY PUNISH PEOPLE BY
TAKING THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE
AWAY FROM THEM.
IF THEY'RE CONVICTED OF CERTAIN
CRIMES ARE ALLOWED JUDGES TO DO
THAT [inaudible]
AND I THINK.
PUNISHING PEOPLE FOR CRIME AND
HAVING --
CONVICTED IF THEY'RE GUILTY IS
IMPORTANT.
I THINK PUNISH THEM BY TAKING
AWAY THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE.
IS A IS A WAY OF JUST MAKING OR
DMV HAVE MORE WORK TO DO.
SO I THINK --
I BETTER DO SOME BILLS ON NOT
CHANGING THAT AND MAYBE.
ST WELL WILL YOU KNOW WITHOUT
CHANGING THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
PENAL CODE IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S A MISDEMEANOR PHONE
OR ANY OF THAT KIND OF STUFF.
WHICH IS SAYING.
WE DON'T WANT TO USE THE PENAL
CODE.
AND AND AND AND ALLOW THE DMV TO
BE BURDEN WITH US.
IMPLEMENTING THE PENAL CODE I
DON'T KNOW WITH PEOPLE.
HAVE EVEN NOTICE THIS ISSUE BUT
BUT I FOUND THAT.
IT'S LITERALLY IN THE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVE THIS PROCESS --
AS PART OF THEIR PUNISHMENT WHEN
THEY COMMIT A CRIME WHETHER IT'S
A MISDEMEANOR OR SOME OTHER KIND
OF CRIME.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT DO YOU --
OR ANYTHING INVOLVING AN
AUTOMOBILE.
TALKING ABOUT NON AUTOMOBILE.
BASIC CRIMES IN ON THAT NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE DRIVING A CAR
USING A CAR AND HE THAT.
THAT SERVICE THANKS SO.
SO I THINK --
I THINK --
OF THOSE THOSE THINGS WILL BE
LOOKED AT IN OUR LEGISLATION I
LIKE YOUR COOPERATION WORKING ON
THAT CERTAINLY.
BECAUSE AND THERE MIGHT BE SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO WE HAVE
TO STRIP AWAY SOME OF THE ADDED.
ASSIGNMENTS OF YOU WANT TO CALL
THAT THE SOCIAL SERVICE
COLLECTION AGENCY --
LIKE THEY ONLY BECOME THAT WE
COULD LOOK AT ALL THOSE THINGS
RIGHT I AGREE --
AND I THINK THAT --
THEY REQUIRE MORE STAFF MORE
TIME I THINK --
OF IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH NOW I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD LOOK AT I
MEAN WE'RE REALISTICALLY MAKE
THE DUTY OF THE FOCUS ON ITS.
CORE MISSION.
OF OF HELPING PEOPLE DRIVE
SUCCESSFULLY IN GETTING THERE --
THAN ANY.
FOR OUR TRAVEL THAT WE WANT TO
HAVE THEM HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE ALL OVER THE WORLD SO.
SO -- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS --
SENATOR BATES IS HERE.
INTERNAL --
JUST FINE NOW I'M.
ACTUALLY OUT ON TO WHAT SENATOR
BAIL SAID ABOUT CHILD
ACCOMMODATING THOSE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS PARTICULAR.
I'M GONNA PUT A SHOUT OUT IN
THERE FOR THE SENIOR COMMUNITY
WHEN I GOT MY DRIVER'S LICENSE I
WAS WITH A COUPLE SENIORS WHO
WERE OUT THE THE COMPUTER ON
STATIONS AND THEY WERE TOTALLY
CONFUSED OF HOW TO FILL OUT.
SO I MAYBE THEY'RE ALREADY ANSEL
AND PAPER.
THAT THE GENTLEMAN THAT STANDING
NEXT TO ME HE JUST WALKED AWAY
SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO START OVER
AGAIN I NEED TO GO TAKE A
COMPUTER CLASS WAS.
IN SO I TRIED TO HELP HIM
THROUGH ON THAT BUT I THINK THAT
SOMETHING THAT THEY'LL BE FEW OF
THOSE PROBABLY.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO
MADE AN APPOINTMENT AND MAYBE
THERE WITHIN A FEW WEEKS OF
EXPIRATION ESPECIALLY UP A
SENIOR AGE.
THE WORRY ABOUT WHETHER YOU'LL
QUALIFY TO TO GET YOUR LICENSE
RENEWED I THINK OF IN PARTICULAR
ON A GROUP IN A LARGER GROUP
POSSIBLY AS THE AS IT GOES HERE
CALIFORNIA TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
CERTAINLY THAT KIANA KIOSK I'M
ASSUMING THAT'S GOING TO BE MORE
ON COMPUTER BASED THAT JOB.
THE INTUITIVE YEAH PRETTY
INTUITIVE AND TELL ME THE LOVELY
MUCH MORE INTUITIVE THAN THE
REAL ID MOTOR VOTER --
PROCESS WITH THAT YET OUT THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL AND THEN THANK
YOU WILL WORK WITH THE ACTING
DIRECTOR WEB ON THAT.
AND THEN ARE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS LIKE TRIPLE A THE I
DON'T LOVES YES AND THEY DO HAVE
FACILITIES THAT PROBABLY WOULD
ACCOMMODATE THESE.
OFFSITE LOCATIONS THEY DO AND I
HAVE MET WITH BOTH THE NORTHERN
CLUBS IN THE SOUTHERN CLUBS AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE EAGER TO DO MORE
WORK FRANKLY --
AND WE'RE EAGER TO HAVE MORE
KIOSK AND THAT'S UNDER WAY WITH
WITH THE STRIKE FORCE VERY GOOD
WELL THANK YOU THOSE ARE MY
THOUGHTS THANK YOU SENATOR BATES --
I HAD A CONSTITUENT --
WHO IS? NINETY TWO WENT TO THE
DAY IN THE OFFICE AND STOOD. FOR
TWO AND A HALF HOURS AND THEN
LEFT BECAUSE SHE'S TOO TIRED.
CALL ME UP AND YOU KNOW I FOUND
OUT ABOUT IT INDIRECTLY AT AND
HAVE FROM HER BUT SHE WHEN.
SHE GOT IT TAKEN CARE OF THE BUT
WITHOUT MY ASSISTANCE OF POINT
OUT HOW.
MY MOTHER.
WELL SHE NEVER COMPLAINS ABOUT
ANYTHING.
SHE'S PROBABLY WATCHING US A
LOVE YOU MAMA --
BUT BUT SHE'S ALWAYS WATCHING
THIS ON TV AND EVERYTHING ALL
THOSE ALL THOSE MEETINGS SHE
MAKES COMMENTS ON ALL YOU PEOPLE.
ALL THE MEMBERSHIPS THAT ONLY
VERY KIND COMMENTS I WELL SHE
SHE SHE SHE THE GROUP BOTH THE
CORRECTION SHE MAKES TOWARDS
MAYOR.
PRETTY STRAIGHT FORWARD ME IN A
MOMENT AND TEN KIDS.
SO I GOT A POINT FROM HER TODAY
BRINGING.
BUT I TAKE --
I TAKE WORKING WITH THE SENIORS.
IF THERE'S A GOOD WAY TO DO A
AND AND THE CENTER AGENCIES ARE
REALLY GOOD AT ANY KIND OF THING
WE CAN DO TO ASSIST THE SENIORS.
AND THEY DO IT AND ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT AREAS LIKE A HEALTH
INSURANCE WE HAVE A WHOLE SYSTEM.
FOR HEALTH INSURANCE TO GET THEM
SIGNED UP --
FOR HEALTH INSURANCE AFTER THE
THE MEDICARE SYSTEM.
AND ALL OUT THERE THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE THAT ASSISTANCE
SENIORS AT THE SENIOR CENTER IS
A SENIOR PROGRAMS.
SO -- I
THINK THIS IS A THIS IS
IMPORTANT PRIORITY THAT WE WORK.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
RUDY --
SALAS SAYS OR OR CENTER NUMBER
GO AHEAD.
IT'S A RUDY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
TO I APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY AND YOU BEING
HERE -- I
TRY TO FOLLOW UP BECAUSE OF YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE STRIKE FORCE AND HAVING THE
REPORT AND HOPEFULLY BY JUNE.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED WEATHER'S
FOR SENIORS ARE DISABLED YOU
KNOW I'M I'M REALLY EXCITED TO
SEE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE GONNA DO
IN TERMS OF I THINK YOU
MENTIONED LIKE THE ONLINE
PRESENCE MAKING IT MORE ROBUST
TO ME THAT MEANS.
YOU KNOW LIKE VIRTUAL CHECK IN
LINES YOU KNOW I CAN DO IT FOR
MY HAIR CUT WHAT CAN I DO IT FOR
DMV -- YOU
KNOW MAYBE GETTING SOME ANSWERS
THAT WAY BUT ALSO EVEN THE THE
KIOSKS THE THIRD PARTY VENDORS
WHICH WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TRIPLE
A I KNOW MY FATHER AS WELL USES
TRIPLE A ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
LIKE LOOK THERE'S NO LINE I CAN
GET IT.
IN AND OUT WITHIN THE HOUR.
YOU KNOW AND SOMETIMES WE'VE
BEEN HEARING THROUGH THE BE.
BUT WHAT I WANTED TO JUST ASK IS
IT ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING AT ALL
OF THESE PROCESS SEES I THINK
IT'S IT'S FANTASTIC AND IT'S
GREAT ESPECIALLY WITH.
REAL LADY AND ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES WE'RE GONNA HAVE MOVING
FORWARD.
IS IN THAT REPORT HE HAS BEEN
OUTLINED THE PROCESSES OF WHICH
YOU'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT THESE
THINGS ARE WILL.
THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
AUTOMATICALLY --
MOVE FORWARD WITH SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STRIKE
FORCED SO LIKE YOU KNOW I CAN.
AFTER THE REPORT COMES OUT MAYBE
I CAN LOG IN AND DO THE VIRTUAL
CHECK IN OR DO THE ONLINE CHAT
IT.
OR TRY TO DO ALL THE SERVICES
THAT I NEED RIGHT AWAY OR THOSE
THINGS YOU CAN ACT I WOULD
IMAGINE THE MORE EXPENSIVE STUFF
YOU COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO GET A BUDGET.
ALLOCATION FOR IT BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING FOR LIKE THE THIRD
PARTY VENDORS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT IN THE CREDIT CARD USE.
YOU KNOW ARE THOSE THINGS THAT
THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATION YOU
JUST AUTOMATICALLY IMPLEMENT.
NUMBER SALAS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION --
WHEN WE ARE ACTING AS I SAID IN
MY TESTIMONY IMMEDIATELY WE'RE
NOT WRITING A REPORT THAT WILL
THEN GO TO THE GOVERNOR AND THEN
THEY'LL TAKE ACTION AND THEN AND
THEN AND THEN?
WE I MEET WEEKLY.
AND ALMOST DAILY REPORT TO LAKE --
AND WE ARE MAKING DECISIONS IN
REAL TIME SO IT WON'T WE'RE NOT
WAITING FOR A REPORT THAT WE'RE
GONNA RIGHT --
ADD THE POP UP A DMV THAT I
MENTIONED TO YOU THAT WE HAVE
MADE A DECISION ABOUT AND WERE
WORKING FOR THOSE KIOSKS --
WE MADE A DECISION THAT WE
NEEDED A HUNDRED MORE IN THE
FIELD THERE THERE I'M GOING TO
BE IN THE FIELD NOW AFTER THE
BUDGET.
IS APPROVED HOPEFULLY --
THERE WILL BE --
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR AN
APPROPRIATION THAT WOULD ALLOW
US TO PUT A HUNDRED MORE IN THE
FIELD.
BY THE END OF THE YEAR BUT TO
FULLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE --
RECOMMENDING ON A REGULAR BASIS
IN REAL TIME AS A STRIKE TEAM
WILL INDEED TAKE --
APPROPRIATION AND WILL INDEED
TAKE ON THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTION
BUT SOME ARE NOT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW LIKE I MENTIONED THE REQUEST
FOR OFFER THAT WE PUT OUT ON THE
STREET. THREE WEEKS AGO HAVE
ALREADY ACCEPTED --
A VENDOR WITH WHO WILL START
NEXT WEEK AND THAT'S ON A READ --
PROCESS RE ENGINEERING OF A
FIELD ASSESSES BUT FROM THOSE
PROCESSES WE WILL THEN --
RE ENGINEERED FIELD OFFICES --
FOR A BETTER FASTER --
METHOD OF PROCESSING ID'S AND
DEALS THE DRIVER'S LICENSE SO
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE TAKING ACTION
RIGHT AWAY.
AND YES SOME OF THE ACTION WILL
NEED -- WILL
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THEN RECOMMENDATION. TO YOU ALL
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATION
PROCESS.
BUT SOME WERE UNDERTAKING RIGHT
AWAY RIGHT NOW OKAY NO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND APPRECIATE
THAT FEEDBACK THAT WE PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW WANT TO
IDENTIFY AN ISSUE THAT.
AND YOU SEE --
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS SOMETHING TO
HELP WITH THE WAIT TIMES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE YOU GUYS ARE
MOVING ON THAT'LL BE NICE AT
LEAST MOVING ON AND THEN I DON'T
KNOW IF I SHOULD ASK YOU WERE
BABY THE DECKS PANEL.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE THIRD PARTY
PROCESSORS LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT
TRIPLE A BUT HE DOES HAVE YOU
GUYS LOOK AT MAYBE EVEN
EXPANDING THAT TO OTHER --
GOVERNMENT OFFICES OR LIKE SAY
TO THE LIBRARIES OF THE KIOSK
FOR INSTANCE WORKS FANTASTIC.
MAYBE YOU DON'T NEED TO GO TO
THE DMV BUT MAYBE YOU FIND IT IN
ANOTHER COUNTY OR CITY.
OFTEN LOOKING SIR IT PUTTING THE
KIOSKS AND OTHER TO RETHINK OR
SINK MORE THOROUGHLY OR MORE
BROADLY ABOUT THE METHODOLOGIES
THAT WERE USED TO PLACE THE A
KIOSK BECAUSE OF BETTER IN THE
FIELD NOW.
AND WE ARE DOING THAT SO SOME OF
THEM AND THEY WERE VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN AS YOU HAVE BEEN
I'M SURE NOW YOU SOME OF THOSE
ARE IN GROCERY STORES.
AND SOME OF THE BEST LOCATIONS
HAVE BEEN FAIRLY NEAR DMV
OFFICES SO YES WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE METHODOLOGIES OF PLACEMENT
OF KIOSKS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING.
THE BEST VALUE OUT OF THEM AND
AS I SAID I'VE MET WITH THE AUTO
CLUB'S AND THEY'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN HAVING MORE KIOSKS
AND ALSO IN THE WALL SERVICES --
SAID LIKE THE ATM THAT WE'RE ALL
USED TO USING --
SO WE'RE EXPLORING THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NUMBER
[inaudible]
COMMON MODE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF DISPATCHER
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ON THIS CHALLENGE I CAN'T
THINK OF ANY MORE DIFFICULT OR
CHALLENGING SITUATIONS OR
THANKLESS.
CHALLENGES THAN THE ONE YOU'VE
ACCEPTED --
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE IT IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAVE YOU TRIED TO
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT DMV --
I HAVEN'T PERSONALLY --
I AM.
NO I HAVE NOT NOT NOT AT THAT
ONE OF THE FIELD OFFICES I HAVE.
CERTAINLY IT SINCE I'VE TAKEN ON
THIS.
ASSIGNMENT I'VE TALKED.
TO I WANT TO SAY HUNDREDS MAYBE
IT'S ON HUNDREDS BUT SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT HAVE I'VE HEARD THE
EXPERIENCES WE WITNESSED THEM IN
SOME OF THE FIELD OFFICES IS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
SO AND I I THINK I HAVE A THIS
IS LIKE.
BUT AND I'LL SPARE YOU MIGHT
PERSONALLY IN ADULTS WITH
ANECDOTES OF FOLKS HAVE COME TO
US -- LET ME
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU EVERY SIX
MONTHS OR SO AS A METHOD OF
QUALITY CONTROL JUST TO TRY TO
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT AND THEN IF
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL ACTUALLY
SHOWING UP FOR THAT APPOINTMENT
IN AND I REALIZE THAT THIS.
INCREDIBLY TIME CONSUMING BUT I
THINK IT MAY GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
WHAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE AND
WHAT FRUSTRATIONS ARE BEING FELT
BY THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN.
I DO THIS WITH OTHER AGENCIES AS
WELLJUST AS A YOU KNOW JOHN Q.
WERE TOM Q. CITIZEN TRIED TO DO
THAT --
INSTANCE THERE'S GOING TO BE
IMPROVEMENTS HERE THE NEXT FEW
YEARS THIS MAY BE AN INTERESTING
WAY FOR YOU TO PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCE THE PROGRESS THAT
THAT WILL BE MADE JUST JUST A
THOUGHT.
NO I THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD
THOUGHT -- I
HAVE ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
STRIKE TEAM ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WORKS AT GOV OPTION IS A
MEMBER OF THE STRIKE TEAM.
SHE DID --
LAST WEEK I BELIEVE IT WAS HE
MADE AN APPOINTMENT SHE MADE
THEY MIGHT POINT IN SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO BUT SHE WENT.
TO AND YOU WAS THERE FOR THE
EXPRESS PURPOSE THE PURPOSE OF
RENEWING HER DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND SHE REALLY WANTED TO GET A
REAL ID.
AND SHE WAS DISCOURAGED FROM
GETTING A REAL ID AND WE ARE
LOOKING INTO IT.
SO WE GET THE DAILY NOT ALL BAD
I MEAN WE HAVE I I WANT TO BE
CAREFUL BECAUSE THE DMV HAS MADE
SOME GREAT IMPROVEMENTS AND SOME
OF THE EXPERIENCES THAT I AM --
CALLED ABOUT OR TOLD ABOUT ON
HAVE BEEN POSITIVE.
IN THEM.
BREAKING MY OWN RULE I ACTUALLY
HAD A WHEN I FINALLY GOT TO A
HUMAN BEING ACTUALLY A VERY GOOD
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT INDIVIDUAL
DMV EMPLOYEE --
TO HEAR THAT.
BUT THE CHALLENGE WAS GETTING TO
THAT INDIVIDUAL DMV EMPLOYEE OR
GOING THE APPOINTMENT AND ANYWAY
I I'M AGAIN I'M NOT GOING TO
BELABOR THIS BUT I DO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TO PERSONALLY EXPERIENCE
WHAT THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN.
EXPERIENCES AND THEN I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO YOU KNOW.
BUCK ON WOULD YOU'RE GONNA
EXPERIENCE PROGRESS OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS IS THINGS
IMPROVE.
I DON'T REALLY HELPS A
PARTICULAR BETWEEN NOW AND JULY
WHEN WHEN THIS ASSIGNMENT I AM
MIGHT AS SIX MONTH ASSIGNMENT SO
I DON'T HAVE COUPLE YEARS I HAVE
SIX MONTHS LESS THAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER OF OTHER
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT --
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
CENTER BALUSTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU.
OUR PANEL TO IS --
THE ACTUALLY THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD LIKE HIM TO COME FOR
THAT'S KATHLEEN WITH THE ACTING
DIRECTOR AND WE HAVE --
HER DEPUTIES --
ROBBIE CROCKETT COLEEN SOLOMON
AND WELCOME TO OUR MEETING AND
GIVE US YOUR PERSPECTIVE
.
THEY WERE AS SOON [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BELL AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE NUMBER
SALAS THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
I AM KATHLEEN WEB THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES AND WITH ME IS
ROBBIE CROCKETT TO MY RIGHT.
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF MINISTRY
SERVICES IN CALLING SOLOMON
WHO'S THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FIELD OPERATIONS DIVISION.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY REGARDING THE
PROGRESS DMV HAS MADE IN
IMPLEMENTING.
THE WORK PLAN TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE WAIT TIMES IMPLEMENT REAL
ID.
AND TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
REGARDING DMV'S ABSENTEEISM WORK
FORCE WELLNESS PROGRAM.
AS THE NEW ACTING DIRECTOR I AM
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO MODERNIZE THE DMV OPERATIONS
TO BETTER SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS.
AS SECRETARY BADGER STATE IN HER
OPENING REMARKS THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF A PROCESS.
FOCUSED UPON DELIVERING SERVICES
TO CUSTOMERS IN THE WAY THEY
WANT TO RECEIVE THEM.
AS I SURE WAS STAFF WE ARE ON A
JOURNEY TO CREATE THE DMV THE
BEST SERVICE OUR CHILDREN AND
THIS WILL REQUIRE A COMMITMENT
FROM THE WHOLE TEAM. TO MAKE
THIS A REALITY.
I AM ALSO VERY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP PROVIDED
BY THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY STRIKE TEAM.
AND THE PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE
THUS FAR TO ENSURE WE ARE
DELIVERING THE SERVICES.
AND TO EFFECTIVELY SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS.
THE DMV OF THE FUTURE IS AN
ACHIEVABLE DESTINATION WE CAN
GET THERE TOGETHER IN TIME.
IN A MOVING TOWARDS THAT
DESTINATION THE DMV IS VERY
COMMITTED TO REDUCING WAIT TIMES
FOR CUSTOMERS OFFERING MORE SELF
SERVICE TRANSACTIONS. TO REDUCE
THE NEED FOR FIELD OFFICE VISITS.
I WISH TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY
SINCE OCTOBER WHEN YOU LAST HAD
A HEARING ON THE ISSUE. FOR NON
APPOINTMENT CUSTOMER PLEASE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE WAIT TIME HAS
NOT EXCEEDED ONE HOUR.
THE MONTHLY AVERAGE FOR
APPOINTMENT WAIT TIMES IS NOT
EXCEEDED FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR THE
PREVIOUS FOUR MONTHS.
AND UPON INITIAL REVIEW
FEBRUARY'S WAIT TIME DATA IS AN
IMPROVEMENT FROM JANUARY.
LAST AUGUST DMV SET A YEAR END
GOAL OF REDUCING Q. WAIT TIMES
TO AN AVERAGE OF FORTY FIVE
MINUTES. FOR NON APPOINTMENT
CUSTOMERS AND FIFTEEN MINUTES
FOR CUSTOMERS WITH APPOINTMENTS.
FOR PRE Q. WAIT TIMES THE GOAL
FOR NON APPOINTMENT CUSTOMERS
WAITING IS NO MORE THAN FIFTEEN
MINUTES AVERAGE.
AND FOR APPOINTMENT CUSTOMERS TO
WAIT NO MORE THAN THREE MINUTES
AVERAGE.
DMV HAS ACHIEVED THE OVERALL
WEIGHT CALL TIMES FOR THE PAST
FIVE CONSECUTIVE MONTHS SINCE
OCTOBER.
AND ALTHOUGH WE'VE ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS IT DOES NOT MEAN OUR WORK
IS DONE.
DEAR WE WILL CONTINUE PROVIDING
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT CUSTOMER
SERVICE TO REDUCE WAIT TIMES.
ENHANCE THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
A DMV FIELD OFFICES AND PROVIDE
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS FOR ADDED
CUSTOMER CONVENIENCE.
OUTSIDE OF THE TRADITIONAL
OFFICE.
OUR SUCCESS REDUCING WAIT TIMES
IS DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTED TO HIRING
NEW EMPLOYEES THAT SOME SINCE
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THROUGH EMERGENCY APPOINTMENTS
AND LIMITED TERM POSITIONS.
TRIAGE IN CUSTOMERS WAITING TO
IMPROVE AND EXPEDITE THE
HANDLING OF TRANSACTIONS.
USING SMART TABLETS TO CHECK
CUSTOMERS INTO THE QUEUE FASTER
AND TO ALSO ASSIST WITH
ASSESSING ONLINE SERVICES OR TO
SCHEDULE AN APPOINTMENT.
PROVIDING AN EXPEDITE LINE FOR
EASIER TRANSACTIONS LIKE
OBTAINING A DRIVING RECORD OR
PICKING UP LICENSE PLATES OR
DISABLE PLACARDS.
PROVIDING TEXT MESSAGE
NOTIFICATIONS TO CUSTOMERS SO
THEY CAN HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
LEAVE THE DMV OFFICE.
IN RETURN WHEN THEIR QUEUE
NUMBERS ABOUT TO BE CALLED.
IMPROVED INTEGRATION OF OUR
DRIVERS LICENSE APPLICATION
PROCESS.
NOW REFER TO IT AS EASE SO
CUSTOMERS SPEND LESS TIME IN A
TECHNICIAN WINDOW.
ADDITIONAL SERVICE HOURS WE ARE
PART TIME IN SIXTEEN OFFICES AND
SATURDAY SERVICES IN SIXTY TWO
OFFICES FROM EIGHT AM TO FIVE PM.
ENHANCING OFFICE PERFORMANCE
INEFFICIENCIES IN SOME OFFICES
FOR CUSTOMERS WAITING THROUGH
PRE SCREENING THEIR DOCUMENTS.
MONITORING FIELD OFFICE WAIT
TIMES A REAL TIME THROUGH THE
DMV COMMAND CENTER.
AND OFFERING ONLINE SERVICES
THAT DO NOT REQUIRE VISITING A
FIELD OFFICE.
THE DMV REMAINS COMMITTED TO
REFINING EXISTING STRATEGIES AND
DEVELOPING NEW ONES TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUSTAIN IMPROVE
THESE WAIT TIME LEVELS.
AS THE SECRETARY MENTIONED THE
INPUT MADE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REAL ID ACT IS.
A SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
LONG WAITS AND WE DO ANTICIPATE.
MORE CUSTOMERS ARRIVING AT OUR
FIELD OFFICES AS WE APPROACH
OCTOBER.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AS REQUIRED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY EVERY CUSTOMER WANTING
A FEDERALLY COMPLIANT LICENSE OR
IDENTIFICATION CARD MUST VISIT A
DMV FIELD OFFICE.
WITH VALID PROOF OF IDENTITY
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND
RESIDENCY ALTERNATIVELY SOME
CUSTER'S MAY CHOOSE TO USE A
PASSPORT OR MILITARY ID FOR REAL
ID PURPOSES.
AND NOT REQUIRE A DMV ISSUED
RELY TEAM. FOR FISCAL YEAR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE'VE ISSUED
A PROCESS WE SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY ONE REAL ID'S.
AND DURING THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THROUGH FEBRUARY.
DMV IS ISSUED A PARTIALLY TWO
POINT THREE MILLION REAL ID'S
AND AS OF FEBRUARY WE'VE ISSUE.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN FOR A
TOTAL OF THREE POINT ONE MILLION
REAL ID'S ISSUE TODAY.
DMV IS WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
REVISING ARE FORECASTING.
AND THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
HOPEFULLY IDENTIFY RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
FORECAST.
CUSTOMER OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
IS A KEY COMPONENT TO INCREASE
PUBLIC AWARENESS.
THIS HELPS ENSURE THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS COME ALL THE DOCUMENTS
NEEDED TO APPLY FOR A REAL ID.
AS PART OF THAT EFFORT THE DMV
IS ESTABLISHED A SPEAKERS BUREAU
TO PROVIDE PRESENTATIONS FOR
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
WE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN EVENTS YOU HOST
FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT DMV IN
OUR VARIOUS SERVICES INCLUDING
REAL ID. FOR ALSO WHERE THAT
MEMBERS OF ACTUALLY REACHED OUT
pALREADY TO ARRANGE THESE --
EVENTS.
IMPLEMENTING REAL ID CONTINUES
TO POSE A CHALLENGE BUT TO BE
VERY HONEST.
DMV IS MORE PREPARED NOW TO
RECEIVE CUSTOMERS THAT COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR.
IN ORDER TO MEET REAL ID DEMANDS
WE ARE ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
ENOUGH EMPLOYEES AVAILABLE AND
FIELD OFFICE IS OPEN TO SERVE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
OUR GOALS CONTINUE TO BE ENSURE
THAT SERVICE WINDOWS ARE
AVAILABLE TO MEET CUSTOMER
DEMAND.
TRIAGE CUSTOMERS TO ENSURE WE
MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCIES AND
PROVIDING CUSTOMER SERVICE.
MAINTAIN STRIKE TEAMS TO ADDRESS
AREAS THAT NEED SPECIAL FOCS.
MONITOR THE WAIT TIMES AT ALL
FIELD OFFICES THROUGH OUR
HEADQUARTERS COMMAND CENTER.
EVALUATE EXPANSE ARSES THAT MAY
BE POVIDED ONLINE.
ASSESS THE NEED FOR OFFICE --
ADDED OFFICE HOURS REVIEW AND
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PERFORMANCE AUDIT.
AND THE GOV OPS REINVENTION
STRIKE TEAM TO USE TO RE DIRECT
CUSTOMERS TO OTHERS SERVICE
CHANNELS.
A SECRETARY BATRA DISCUSSED IN
HER OPENING REMARKS WE WANT TO
EXPAND TRANSACTIONS THAT
CUSTOMERS CAN COMPLETE.%
WITHOUT VISITING FIELD OFFICES
INCLUDING BY AUGUST.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN
ADDING THE D. ADDING TO THE DMV
WEBSITE THE ABILITY FOR
CUSTOMERS TO OBTAIN A DUPLICATE
REGISTRATION CARD OR DUPLICATE
VEHICLE REGISTRATION STICKERS.
AND BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN ADDING FOR NEW
SERVICES TO SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS.
SO CUSTOMERS MAY RECEIVE A COPY
OF A DRIVING RECORD OF VEHICLE
RECORD.
REPLACEMENT REGISTRATION AND
REPLACEMENT VEHICLE REGISTRATION
STICKER.
DMV WILL CONTINUE WITH THE FRONT
END APPLICATIONS SUSTAINABILITY
PROJECT TO MODERNIZE ITS VEHICLE
REGISTRATION CONTROL KASHER.
BUSINESS APPLICATIONS IN ENSURE
THE SYSTEM'S ARCHITECTURAL LINES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND STATES
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY STRATEGIC
DIRECTION.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH ALL THESE
GOALS WE ENSURE WE PROVIDE OUR
EMPLOYEES THE APPROPRIATE TOOLS
SO THEY CAN PROVIDE.
SUPERIOR CUSTOMER SERVICE OFTEN
UNDER VERY DEMANDING SITUATIONS
SUCH AS WORKING SIX DAYS A WEEK
AND SOME OF OUR OFFICES.
LAST OCTOBER DMV SHARED WITH
THIS COMMITTEE THEIR ABSENTEEISM
RATE WAS CLOSE 230%.
THAT NUMBER WAS ALARMINGLY HIGH
WHICH THE COMMITTEE FOUND VERY
CONCERNING AND I CAN KERN.
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY
THIS INFRMATION.
AT THE TIME THE ABSENT HE IS A
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT MULTIPLE
FACTORS SUCH AS APPROVED TIME
OFF.
MATERNITY OR PATERNITY LEAVE
CIVIC OR MILITARY DUTY AMONG
OTHER FACTORS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF AN OFFICE
ROSTER HAD TEN EMPLOYEES
SCHEDULED TO WORK THAT DAY BUT
ONLY EIGHT EMPLOYEES WERE
PRESENT.
THEN THE ABSENTEEISM RATE WAS
20%.
THIS WAS REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE
ABSENCE WAS SCHEDULED OR
UNSCHEDULED.
BECAUSE OF THIS METHODOLOGY THE
DEPARTMENT REPORTED A VERY HIGH
ABSENTEES ARRAY AND WE WERE
ASKED TO COME UP WITH A PLAN TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
IN OUR EVALUATION OF OTHER
ABSENTEEISM METHODOLOGIES WE
DETERMINE AS MORE APPROPRIATE TO
REDEFINE ABSENTEEISM WITH THE
METRIC SIMILAR TO THAT USED BY
THE UNITED STATES FEDERAL BUREAU
OF LABOR STANDARDS.
WHICH IS BASED ON ON SCHEDULED
ABSENCES.
TOWARDS THAT END THE DMV'S FIELD
OPERATIONS DIVISION BEGAN
GATHERING DATA UTILIZING THIS
ABSENTEEISM METRIC.
STARTING OCTOBER TWENTY SECOND
OF SINCE THEN THE AVERAGE
ABSENTEEISM RATE HAS BEEN SIX
POINT 2%.
IN COMPARISON 230%.
THE SIX POINT 2% ABSENTEES ARRAY
PROVIDES BOTH RELIEF AND
REASSURANCE FOR DMV TO CONTINUE
TO IDENTIFY WAYS IN WHICH THE
ABSENT TO USE A RAKE CAN BE
LOWERED.
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE HEALTHY.
AND THE WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT IS
PRODUCTIVE. TO HELP PROVIDE MORE
SUPPORT FROM BOYS THE DEPARTMENT
ESTABLISHED CONVENE THE WELLNESS
COMMITTEE.
IDENTIFIED WELLNESS BOOSTERS AT
EACH WORK LOCATION TO DEVELOP IN
EMPLOYEE WELLNESS SERVING.
D. REDISTRIBUTE THE ALL EMPLOYEE
WELLNESS SERVING ON JANUARY
THIRTIETH.
TWENTY NINETEEN WITH FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
RESPONDING AS OF FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH.
THE DMV ANTICIPATES THE SURVEY
RESULTS WILL BE AVAILABLE AT THE
END OF THE MONTH.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
PARTICIPATE IN A HEALTH
ENHANCEMENT RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION SURVEY WHICH
DESIGNED TO HELP ORGANIZATIONS
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE OF
HEALTH AT THE WORK SITE.
AND ASSIST IN DETERMINING
CONDITIONS OF SUPPORT WELLNESS
2% -- AREAS
FOR IMPROVEMENT.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT COMPONENT IS
THE CURRENT EXTERNAL EVALUATIONS
TAKING PLACE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING ADDITIONAL INPUTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AUDIT
IN THE STRIKE TEAMS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE DMV CAN IMPLEMENT TO HELP
IMPROVE A MODERNIZE OUR
ORGANIZATION.
AND ENSURE WE ARE PROVIDING
SUPERIOR CUSTOMER SERVICE WITH
REASONABLE WAIT TIMES.
THE DEPARTMENT STILL HAS A LONG
ROAD AHEAD OF IT.
BUT YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT.
AND THAT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CONTINUE MAKING PROGRESS AND ALL
THE ISSUES DISCUSSED BEFORE YOU
THIS AFTERNOON.
INCLUDING PROVIDING THE
COMMITTEE WITH AN UPDATED WORK
PLAN IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
I WANT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS OUR EFFORTS
AND WE ARE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION --
IN TERMS OF THE REAL STATUS OF
THE OF THE REAL ID.
I'M INTERESTED IN.
LOOKING OUT HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
REAL ID'S YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO ISSUE AN IS THAT IS IT
CLIMBING.
ON A PER MONTHLY BASIS.
AND HOW HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
ACCOMMODATE --
WITH YOUR PLANNING THAT YOU HAVE.
TO MEET THE DEADLINE THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO IN IN MY SHORT TIME HERE A
DMV IN THE DATA THAT I'VE LOOKED
AT YES WE CAN SEE AN UP TECH AND
I THINK --
ROBBIE CAN PROBABLY SPEAK TO THE
PRIOR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
FORECASTING THAT WE'VE DONE.
WELL I'M LOOKING AT LIKE OKAY
GOT SOMEBODY DONE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE --
HOW MANY MORE THAT ARE ON THAT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DO?
AND ARE YOU GONNA DO BETWEEN NOW
AND THE DEADLINE HOW MANY ARE
YOU GOING TO HAVE TO DO MORE.
OF WORK PER MONTH.
THEN YOU'RE DONE IN THE PAST.
YEAH I WOULD ANTICIPATE BASED ON
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS AS MORE
PEOPLE BECOME AWARE THAT THEY
NEED TO REALIZE JEAN AS WE GET
CLOSER TO THE DEADLINE.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN PEOPLE COMING TO THE
OFFICE -- IN
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS WERE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND FORECASTING THAT
INFORMATION AND WHAT WOULD IT
TAKE FROM A RESOURCE STANDPOINT
OR TO ADDRESS THAT INCREASE ARE
YOU EXPECTING A SURGE RIGHT AT
THE END LIKE.
PROCRASTINATOR IS OR LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE THAT
[inaudible]
EXPECT.
THE EIGHTY MODERN FROM HEAVEN OR
SOME KIND OF THING THAT CREATES --
AN EASIER PROCESS OR SOME KIND
OF WAY OF GETTING AROUND THE
REQUIREMENT OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT ARE YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT.
ALWAYS HAVE EXCUSES FOR NOT
DOING ANYTHING TO WRITE THE END.
ARE YOU EXPECTING --
A LARGE AMOUNT OF THAT TO CORRER
OR EXPECTED TO CALIFORNIA'S TO
COME INTO THE OFFICE.
ON A STEADY STREAM --
IN TERMS OF THE RELY DAY WHICH
ONE ARE YOU EXPECTING.
WELL I THINK IF WE LOOK AT THE
TRENDS AND ALL THE PRODUCTS THAT
THE DMV ACTUALLY HANDLES.
WE ALWAYS HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING IN CLOSE TO THE
VERY I THINK NEXUS OF THEIR
DEADLINE --
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
NON APPOINTMENT ACTIVITY THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS --
THAT BEING SAID I THINK WE ARE
PUTTING OUT WHAT I CALL FULL
COURT EFFORT TO REALLY RAISE
AWARENESS REMIND PEOPLE.
OF THE REQUIREMENT FOR THEM TO
HAVE IT IF THEY'RE GOING TO
TRAVEL CERTAINLY IF THEY HAVE A
PASSPORT THEY CAN CERTAINLY
TRAVEL WITH THEIR CURRENT
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND A PASSPORT --
PEOPLE MAY CHOOSE THAT THAT'S
NOT A WAY THAT THEY WANT TO
TRAVEL AFTER THEY START DOING
THAT SO WE ANTICIPATE.
PEOPLE MAY CHANGE THEIR IDEA OF
TRAVELING WITH BOTH DOCUMENTS TO
YOUR POINT WE'RE TRYING TO
ANTICIPATE WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW
FROM A KIND OF A HUMAN TRENDING
STANDPOINT WITH OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT WE HANDLE --
WE KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE THOSE
THAT WILL PLAN AHEAD AND THEN-THERE WILL BE THOSE ARE PROBABLY
PUSH IT TO THE VERY LAST MINUTE.
AND ATTEMPT TO ACCOMMODATE THAT
I THINK TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE SEARCHES I THINK CALLING CAN
SPEAK TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN --
AS FAR AS SEASONAL SURGES WE
KNOW THAT SUMMER MONTHS ACTUALLY
BRING SURGES AND SO WE'RE
ANTICIPATING A SUMMER SURGE OF
PEOPLE COMING TO OUR OFFICES AND
WE'RE ALREADY LOOKING AT
BRINGING IN THE OUTSIDE
RESOURCES ARE WORKING WITH OUR
FELLOW DEPARTMENTS TO COME IN
AND HELP WITH.
HELP US IN THE SAME MANNER THEY
HELPED US OVER THE SUMMER
SOMEBODY --
PEOPLE PER MONTH HAVE YOU BEEN
DOING IN TERMS OF WHAT'S YOUR
AVERAGE PER MONTH TO TO HANDLE.
TERMS OF YOU HAVE A REAL ID OR
LIGHT.
THAT'S ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND A MONTH THERE ARE FOUR
THOUSAND A MONTH.
IF YOU KEPT OUT RATE HOW MANY
WOULD NOT BE REGISTERED BY THE
TIME THE DEADLINE.
FOR A SUBSTANTIAL NOW WE DO
ENVISION ALMOST LIKE WHAT'S THE
NUMBER -- IF
YOU IF YOU DID THREE OR FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND A MONTH.
LIKE FROM NOW TO THE DEADLINE
HOW MONEY --
ROUGHLY FIVE MILLION A YEAR SO
HOW WE ENVISION AS EARLY TO FROM
THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL WITH LIKE
A HYBRID OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IS WE THINK THAT THEY'LL BE A
NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT ARE COMMON
PRIOR TO THE DEADLINE BUT WE DO
ENVISIONED A BE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT COME IN AFTER THE
DEADLINE ON THEIR NORMAL CYCLE.
THAT DON'T NECESSARILY NEED A
REAL ID AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME
AND SO WHERE THEY WOULD BE --
BETWEEN NOW AND THE ADDED INTO
THE REAL ID DEADLINE WOULD YOU
EXPECT A MONTH AND IN THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT
FORTH IT WAS ROUGHLY RIGHT
AROUND FOURTEEN MILLION THAT WAS --
ANTICIPATED TO GO I'M PRIOR TO
OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY HOW MANY A MONTH.
WOULD YOU EXPECT --
HACER MANY TIMES AS I WANT YOU
KNOW I'M HERE.
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE SO.
I'M GIVING YOU A QUESTION ABOUT
STE SIX TIMES NOW.
HOW MANY MONTHS TO WOULD YOU
EXPECT?
I WOULD SAY IT'S PROBABLY
BETWEEN FIVE AND SIX NINE
THOUSAND MONTH OKAY ARE YOU --
YOU SO OU THINK THAT IF YOU HAD
FIVE OR 600-060-01000 A MONTH.
YOU WOULD EXPECT TO FINISH ALL
THE IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THE ONES BEFORE OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY SO IN A PROPOSAL I
PROPOSALS ON THE ONE THAT WILL
PUT IN FRONT OF THE THE
LEGISLATURE AS IT RELATES TO HAS
A MULTI YEAR SO GOES AFTER.
THAT --
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY SAY
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO FINISH A
MALL BY OCTOBER THAT IS CORRECT
THAT IS NOT A YEAR YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO FINISH.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THAT AS
OF RIGHT NOW TO WHERE YOU THINK
YOU ARE GOING TO FINISH --
IT'S NORMALLY PROBABLY ANYWHERE
FROM YOU KNOW TO GIVE ME A
NUMBER YOU'RE ASKING YOUR
QUESTION FOUR TO SIX MILLION
PROBABLY ORDER SIX MILLION SO.
SO HOT WHAT PERCENTAGES THAT OF
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
REMAINING.
MMHM SO IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
OUR NUMBERS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
CLOSE TO TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
LICENSED DRIVERS YEAH.
AND SO.
I THINK THE LAST NUMBERS ON
THROUGH ON HOW MANY YEARS SO.
FOR FOR AND WE'VE DONE ABOUT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS MILLION SO
FAR -- WE
ALSO KNOW OF THAT NUMBER --
THERE'S BEEN AN INDICATION ABOUT
40% OF THOSE FOLKS ACTUALLY ALSO
HOLD PASSPORTS.
YEAH -- SO
IF YOU BACK THAT NUMBER OUT NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT MAYBE.
IT AGAIN THE QUESTION IS IF YOUR
PASSPORT HOLDER DO YOU STILL
WANT TO DO A REAL IDE A LOT OF
THIS IS SOMEWHAT SPECULATION OF
GUESSING --
WE ANTICIPATE NOT EVERYBODY IS
GOING TO COME AND GET A REAL ID
THAT'S BEEN THE WHOLE
FORECASTING BECAUSE OF THE
ABILITY TO USE ALTERNATIVE.
METHODS FOR TRAVEL --
SO I THINK LEAVE EVERYBODY WORE.
NO IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT.
OBSERVE THE FOUR TO SIX MILLION
THAT WON'T ALBUM BY THE TIME.
YOU -- IT
THE DEADLINE RIGHT.
SO YOU SENT.
I'M IN THE OUT FISCAL YEARS
CORRECT.
SO SO YOU FINISH THE REST OF
THEM.
BY OCTOBER --
TWENTY TWENTY IDEALLY THAT WOULD
BE THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO SCORES OF
THAT ERA.
THE NUMBERS --
JUNE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION.
MINUS THREE THAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE THAT'S TWENTY FOUR BILLION
[inaudible]
MINUS.
SIX THE H. EIGHTEEN MILLION.
I'M DOING MY REFER TO CARE.
THERE IS THERE TO DO IT RIGHT
WHEN I'M DOING IT RIGHT RIGHT.
WELL I GOT I GOT A I'M JUST
HOUSE NEWS CHRIS OR EIGHTEEN
MILLION.
SO HOW MANY MONTHS YOU HAVE LEFT.
THROUGH OCTOBER ARE THROUGH THE
END OF YOUR TO THE DEADLINE.
HOW MUCH YOU HAVE LEFT NOW
[inaudible]
WELL. EIGHT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
SIXTEEN NATO YOU'RE TALKING A
MILLION A MONTH YOU HAVE TO DO
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
IF YOU WANT TO FINISH A MALL IF
YOU'RE INTO THE MALL.
BY SUBTRACTED SIX OUT.
SO EIGHTEEN YEAR MILLION A MONTH
YOU SAY YOU'RE.
ABLE TO DO FROM FIVE HONORED.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND SO YOU
STILL SHORT.
FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND A MONTH.
A THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET A SO HOW ARE WE GOING TO
CLOSE THAT GAP THEM.
THAT'S THE QUESTION RIGHT. TO AN
ARITHMETIC HERE.
ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO CLOSE THE
GAP THIS IS THE QUESTION.
WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES ARE
LEADS TO THE NEXT FUNDING
REQUEST AS YOU MAY BE AWARE IT'S
ALWAYS A HOUSES FOR MORE MONEY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT OTHER THINGS YOU'RE GONNA?
YOURASSIST FOR MONEY GOOD WITH
OTHER THINGS.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA DO ONLY ONE
TYPE OF DEFICIENCIES YEAH I I'VE
YEAH I THINK TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS A NUMBER I I THINK
SECRETARY BACHELOR ADDRESS A
NUMBER OF THINGS I HAVE TO TAKE
PLACE.
ONE HOW DO WE MAKE THE REAL ID
PROCESS MORE EFFICIENT --
HOW DO WE TAKE LESS TIME OFF THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE TO PROCESS
THE REAL ID WE'RE LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF ALTERNATIVES TO DO
THAT RIGHT NOW?
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT'S
GOING TO BE VERY HELPFUL IS HOW
DO WE ACTUALLY.
INSURE THAT THE TRANSACTIONS
GOING ON IN THE FIELD OFFICE ARE
FOR WHEN A CALL COMPLICATED OR
IN PERSON TRANSACTIONS.
AND MOVE AS MANY SIMPLIFIED
TRANS.
EITHER A KIOSK ENVIRONMENT OR A
MUCH IMPROVED WEBSITE
ENVIRONMENT --
CITY YOUR POINT YOU KNOW I THINK.
I DON'T KNOW IF CALLING YOU JUST
MADE A ON TRANSACTIONS I'M I'M A
GET CONFUSING Là.
NUMBER.
OKAY CAN YOU PREPARE FOR ME A
ONE PIECE OF PAPER.
THE ARITHMETIC ON HOW MANY
PEOPLE NEED TO GET THIS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE MONSTER TO PLAY
DO WHAT YOUR PLAN IS SO I CAN
JUST?
WE CAN DO THAT.
AND THEN WHAT YOUR PLAN TO YOU
SAID DID YOU HAVE A PLAN NOW TO
DO. FOR FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND A
MINDSET OF THE MAX YOU KNOW
BUILDING UP FROM.
RIGHT NOW YOU DON'T THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND A MONTH IN THE
PAST SO YOU'RE BUILDING UP TO DO.
FOUR FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CORRECT.
A MONTH SO YOU'RE GONNA DO MORE.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE IMPROVEMENTS
FOR MAKING BUT THEN YOU STILL
HAVE A GAP TO CLOSE.
WE ARE NOT.
SO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO CLOSE
THAT GAP IS.
ONE TRYING TO GET OUT I MEAN I'M
I'M I'M I'M.
THIS IS KIND OF WHAT THE PUBLIC
WANTS TO KNOW THEY WANT TO KNOW.
LIKE WHAT WHAT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN HERE SO THE KIND OF LIKE
LOOK AT IT.
THIS IN THE WAY I AM THEY LOOK
AT A KIND OF THE WAY I LOOK AT
IT.
ARE YOU GOING TO CLOSE THE GAP I
MEAN WE WE APPRECIATE THE YOU
KNOW THAT'S A STEADY IMPROVEMENT
DENTURE [inaudible]
MAKING [inaudible]
BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE
FACING IN TERMS OF THE REAL IDEA
AND MAYBE SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS.
HOW WE GONNA GET BEYOND THAT AND
DO MORE?
SO WE HAVE TO KIND OF REALLY
DEAL DWELL ON IT THE REALITY
SENSE THAT WE HAVE ON THIS OKAY
SO.
I WANT YOU TO HELP ME UNDERSTAND
IT SO WHEN I SAY ME I MEAN MY
COLLEAGUES.
IN THE SENATE THE RING ON THE
WORKING ON THIS OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS.
AND THE ASSEMBLY COURSE.
COULD I CAN AS A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS --
DID YOU OF ARE YOU LOOKING AT
THE ISSUE OF I THINK CENTER
MORALE YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
SO -- GET
YOU IN A SECOND --
LOOKING AT THESE [inaudible]
STRIPPING AWAY [inaudible]
OF SOME EXTRANEOUS THINGS THAT
THE DMV DOES --
LIKE IN THE LIKE I MENTIONED THE
PENAL CODE I MENTIONED --
POSSIBLY LOOKING AT MULTI YEAR
REGISTRATION OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS.
DO YOU THINK THOSE THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS --
SHOULD BE DONE IN TERMS OF THE
CHANGING OF THE STRUCTURE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE DMV.
THAT WOULD HELP YOU --
PLEASE YOUR WORK.
I WOULD SAY WE WOULD WELCOME THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF LOOKING AT
THE BUSINESS MODEL FOR DMV AND
WHAT SHOULD BE OUR CORE MISSION
ANNA THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO
PROCESS THE PRODUCTS THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR UNDER THAT CORE
MISSION WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THOSE --
IDEAS.
OR WELCOME TO GO AHEAD AND AND
VISIT WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
THOSE IDEA --
WE WE TALKED ABOUT IT --
IN IN THE FALL HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE IDEAS SINCE
THEN.
AND GIVEN US WOMEN COME KIND OF
THOUGHT ON THOSE SUBJECTS.
ANYTHING RELATED TO LEGISLATION
OF THOSE TYPES OF THINGS WE'D
WORK WITH OUR AGENCY AND WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THAT --
AS FAR AS ME COMING IN I HAVEN'T
BEEN PRIVY TO THAT CONVERSATION
I WAS LOOKING AT THAT BUT
CERTAINLY WE WOULD AND BROUGHT
HIM UP BEFORE YEAH WE WOULD BE
WELCOME TO EXPLORE THOSE BRING
THEM UP I JUST WANT TO KNOW IF
YOU DONE ANYTHING OR YOU JUST
KIND.
OF PUT IN A FILE SOMEPLACE.
YOU KNOW.
WE WE WERE TRYING TO WE'RE
TRYING.
TO WORK WITH YOU AND AND ONE OF
THE WAYS OF WORKING WITH US IS
TO RESPOND WHEN WE ASKED YOU
ABOUT THINGS.
THAT'S KIND OF WHY I'M ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE DID
ASSN IN THE FALL.
YES SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS IN
THE FALL WE WANT WE WANT TO SEE
IF YOU CAN --
HELP WORK WORK WITH US ON THE
SIX OKAY SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
GOOD --
SERVICE SEVERAL HAS SOME
QUESTIONS EITHER A RUDY YOU HAVE
OKAY SENATE-ROOM MIKE MORRELL
MIKE MIKE YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU BY THE WAY ARE YOU A
COUPLE QUESTIONS THIS IS PASS
THE WITH THE REAL ID SINCE FOR
ON THE SUBJECT IT IS --
TO BETTER NATIONAL SECURITY WHAT
ARE JUST SO IF YOU CAN WALK ME
THROUGH WHAT YOUR STANDARDS ARE
FOR YOUR PROCESSING FOR REAL
ID'S -- DO
YOU ACCEPT FOR EXAMPLE --
IF IT'S NOT CLEAR THE NUMBERS OR
ITS LAMINATED DO YOU ACCEPT
THOSE --
ID'S INFER SO SECURITY CARTER OR
BIRTH CERTIFICATES BEEN
LAMINATED DELUXE IS THAT PARTY
WHAT ARE YOUR WHAT DO YOU ACCEPT
WHAT DON'T YOU EXCEPT.
I THINK FOR THAT QUESTION ALL
TURN TO OUR DEBBIE DIRECTOR
FIELD OPERATIONS TO WALK YOU
THROUGH WHAT THEY DO IN THE
FIELD.
OKAY GET AFTERNOON I'M CENTERS
TO BACK IN YOUR QUESTION OF WHAT
IS REQUIRED FOR A REAL LADY IT'S
THREE DIFFERENT PROCESSES ONE
YOU PROVIDE AN IDENTITY DOCUMENT.
THERE IS A HOST OF DIFFERENT
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS FIRST
CERTIFICATE PASSPORT THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS YOU CAN I GET YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY CARD.
I W. TWO OR ON ANOTHER A HOST OF
DIFFERENT DOCUMENTATION AND ALSO
RESIDENCY IT ESTABLISHES YOUR
DELL LAPTOP MISSILE IN
CALIFORNIA TO ANSWER YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION.
A BIRTH CERTIFICATE FOR EXAMPLE
IF DOC AUTHENTICATION PROCESS
WHERE WE ACTUALLY HANDLE THE
DOCUMENTS.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A SPECIFIC
SECURITY FEATURES REYES AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE THAT WOULD
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT TO DO THAT. ONE OTHER
QUESTION JUST TO APPROXIMATE OUT
OF THE THREE MILLION LET'S SAY.
HOW MANY OF THOSE THINGS IS
THOSE DOCUMENTS PLEASE IDC THINK
YOU'LL RUN INTO THERE WILL NOT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A REAL ID?
I'M AGAIN I AM ALSO NEW TO FIELD
OPERATIONS DIVISION AS WELL AND
IN MY TENURE IN FIELD OPERATIONS
DIVISION AND IT REALLY GOES BACK
TO EDUCATING THE CUSTOMER WE'VE
REALLY TALKED ABOUT CUSTOMER
PREPAREDNESS.
OUT REACH NUMBER OUT THERE ARE
MORE OUT REACHING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND LETTING THEM KNOW
AND IT'S REQUIRED I ACTUALLY
FIND IT THE COMMUNITY HOGS
PREPARED AND READY TO GO.
UP AND NOT AS PART OF OUR TRIAGE
AS WELL WHEN YOU STEP INTO OUR
OFFICE RICH REIMAGINE YOUR
DOCUMENTS TO LOOK AT THEM. TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE AND WHAT YOU
NEED.
IF NOT ME LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
SEND YOU HOME GIVE YOUR RETURN
APPOINTMENT THAT DAY OR THE NEXT
DAY WE DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE TO
WAIT IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE NOT ACCEPTING WHAT WHAT'S
THE PERCENTAGE THAT YOU'RE
CATCHING NOW THAT ARE NOT I'M I
CAN'T.
HEAR IT IT'S NOT HIGH I CAN'T
GIVE YOU I CAN'T QUANTIFY IT BUT
TALKING TO MY FIELD OFFICE STAFF
IT'S IT'S NOT A HIGH PERCENTAGE.
COULD YOU COULD YOU LET US KNOW
THAT IF WHEN I ABSOLUTELY YES I
CAN GO BACK INTO THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR BILL.
THANK.
THANK YOU SIR AROUND THANK OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M SURE --
SALAS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATORS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
JUST COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ALSO ON THAT THE REAL
ID BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE CENTER BELLS
IDENTIFIED AS A MAJOR ISSUE AND
IF IT'S AN EIGHTEEN MILLION GAP
OR ARE SOME SEGMENT OF THAT --
BUT BASS OF SOLDIER MORALES
QUESTIONING TO SIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE FOR
INSTANCE --
YOU KNOW MISS WHAT WE HAD TALKED
ABOUT THE KIOSKS MAYBE USING
THAT FOR SOME OTHER EFFICIENCIES.
WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE WOULD WE BE
ABLE TO USE THE KIOSK FOR THE
REALLY I WILL SAY I'LL GO ON THE
RECORD SAYING YES THAT'S
AFFIRMATIVE HAS TO BE IN PERSON
PER TE FEDERAL LAW.
OKAY MEMORY THINGS COULD BE DONE.
SOME PLUMERI THINGS FOR THE REAR
BEFORE YOU [inaudible]
APPEAR PERSONALLY.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND WE DO HAVE
ELECTRONIC DRIVER'S LICENSE
APPLICATION AND THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS CAN LOG ON FILL THAT
OUT AHEAD OF TIME AND BRING
THOSE ORIGINAL THOSE ORIGINAL
DOCUMENTS YOU KNOW THE OFFICE.
READ ON TO PULL THAT DOWN IT
JUST BE OUR TRANSACTION TIME.
AND AND TO BE PREPARED AS WE
SAID LOOK AT OUR INTERNET I KNOW
THAT SECRETARY ABOUT HER AND AND
A STRIKE TEAM ARE REALLY LOOKING
AT HOW TO REINVENT NOT TO MAKE
IT MORE CUSTOMER FRIENDLY.
THAN WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
INFORMATION I CAN FIND THAT
RIGHT AWAY.
OKAY I WOULD I WOULD OFFER TO IS
WITH THE OROVILLE THAT SECRETARY
BACHELOR SPOKE ABOUT ON THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE IS FOCUSED
ON THE REAL ID PROCESS IN THE
OFFICE AND AND THROUGH THAT
ASSESSMENT WE ALSO HOPE TO
IDENTIFY SOME OTHER INNOVATIONS
THAT WE CAN INTRODUCE THE DMV
OFFICE.
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
OKAY GIVEN THAT THE I WAS
WONDERING HOW I REMEMBER A FEW
YEARS BACK YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I THINK WAS DEALING
WITH -- A
BACKLOG OF LIKE PASSPORTS AND
SOME ISSUES LIKE THAT HAVE WE
LOOKED AT THE DMV MAYBE BRINGING --
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL FROM OTHER
AGENCIES ARE HIRING A BUNCH OF
FELLOWS TO ACTUALLY --
HELP WITH THE REAL LADY PROBLEM
BECAUSE WE KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
RAMP UP.
AT THE CLOSER YOU GET TO THE
DEADLINE I WOULD IMAGINE MORE
PEOPLE OR THEN.
HAVE MORE OF AN URGENCY TO GO
GET THIS DONE ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT TRAVEL.
RIGHT BECAUSE THIS COULD BE USED
YOU'LL NEED IT AT EVERY DOMESTIC
AIRPORT IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
BUT HAS THE DEPARTMENT LOOKED AT
THAT ARE WE WAITING FOR THE
STRIKE TEAM TO LOOK AT THAT AS A
POSSIBLE SOLUTION OR OR
SOMETHING TO HELP GET AT THIS.
GROWING GAP THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS AT THE THE
REAL ID.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
MEMBERS SALAS --
AND ACTUALLY WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT THAT HAVE ROBBIE SPEAK TO
SOME OF THE STAFFING NUMBERS
THEY'RE A PART OF OUR OWN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE --
WE ALSO HAVE REACHED OUT TO OUR
FELLOW DEPARTMENTS --
THAT WAS PART OF THE COST WE
PAID FOR FOR THE SUMMER SURGE --
COOLEY SOLOMON I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT PREPARING FOR THE
NEXT SUMMER'S SURGEON WORKING
WITH OUR FELLOW DEPARTMENTS TO
BRING IN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WHERE THE DEMANDS ARE THERE.
YOU KNOW I THINK WHEN WE HAVE
TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF FIELD
OFFICES WE HAVE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE --
THOSE DEMANDS ARE ACTUALLY
DIFFERENT IN EVERY FIELD OFFICE
AND SOME OF OUR MORE RURAL AREAS
THE DEMANDS WE CAN CERTAINLY
HANDLE TYPICALLY WITH THE STAFF
WE HAVE ON WHEN WE GET OUR MORE
METROPOLITAN AREAS.
WE OFTENTIMES SEE A HIGHER A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING IN AND
NEEDING ASSISTANCE SO IT'S ALSO
PREPARING REGIONALLY AND BY
OFFICE FOR THOSE DEMANDS WE
ANTICIPATE COMING AND PROBABLY
DO YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT AN
INSOLENT CHIME IN REGARDS TO
WHEN WE WERE DOING BEFORE THE
FUNDING REQUEST FOR REAL.
ID AND IT WAS ONLY FUNDED FOR
TWO YEARS SO AS LAST FISCAL YEAR
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR AND ANOTHER
FUNDING REQUEST IS GOING TO GO
IN FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AS PART OF THE THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY TEN IT WAS A PLACE
HOLDER PROPOSAL AND SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO PUT FORWARD A REQUEST
THAT WOULD HAVE RESOURCES FOR
THE REMAINING FISCAL YEARS.
OKAY SO YOU'RE TRYING TO WORK AT
IT GETTING SOME OF THE HEARING A
RAMP UP.
OR YOU CAN --
AT HAND IS THAT UNDER HE SAID
WE'VE ALREADY FUNDED THAT FOR
THESE LAST --
TWO FISCAL CYCLES.
SO THEN GOING TO SENATOR BELL'S
COMMENT SO COME MADE JUNE SHOULD
WE EXPECT.
THERE WILL BE ANOTHER BUDGET
AUGMENTATION REQUESTS THERE WILL
BE ANOTHER FUNDING REQUEST AS IT
RELATES TO FOR THE REMAINING
FISCAL YEARS.
WE PUT A THOUSAND HOW MANY HOW%
MANY IN THE LAST I RUN A
THOUSAND ONE RIGHT NOW HOUSE AND
WORKERS WE PROVED ALREADY.
GOOD SUCH MORE.
BASICALLY.
BUT IT MARK OKAY AND THEN HAVE
TWO OTHER QUESTIONS. TWO OTHER
QUESTIONS --
BECAUSE YOU GUYS WERE GETTING
READY FOR THIS AND OBVIOUSLY --
YOU KNOW ANECDOTALLY WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT DMV AND SOME OF THE ISSUES
BACK HOME.
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S A RED.
I THINK I AM PROUD ABOUT --
LIKE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T GET
A DRIVER'S LICENSE --
TO THAT ISSUE GET CORRECTED IS
THAT COMPLETELY DONE WAS THE
SOURCE IDENTIFIED IN OUR WE
MOVING FORWARD IN CORRECTING
THAT BECAUSE IF YOU KNOW IF WE
CAN GET THAT RIGHT HOW READING
AT THE REAL ID THING RIGHT.
IF YOU COULD JUST COMMENT ON
SOME OF THAT PLEASE THAT THAT
MATTER HAS BEEN RESOLVED --
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THAT WAS
ACTUALLY DATING BACK TO SOME OF
OUR OLD CODING INFORMATION THAT
THE SECRETARY SPOKE ABOUT --
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM FOR THE DMV
THAT DATES BACK TO PROBABLY THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES --
I DON'T HAVE PEOPLE THAT ALWAYS
FULLY KNOW ALL THE CODES AND SO
ONE OF THINGS WE DISCOVERED WAS
A C THAT WAS EMBEDDED.
IN OUR DRIVER'S LICENSE RENEWAL
ACTIVITIES THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT AND SO THAT TRIGGERED --
SOME ISSUES FOR US FROM A
PROCESSING STANDPOINT WE'RE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THAT AFTER WE DID
SOME RECALLS ANALYSIS.
WE'VE ACTUALLY FIX THAT ISSUE
AND WE HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
FOLKS THAT WERE AFFECTED BY IT
AND AS OF LAST WEEK WE ACTUALLY
HAD RESOLVED ALL OF THOSE
DRIVERS LICENSE ISSUES AND HAVE
MAILED OFF FOLKS ON DRIVER'S
LICENSE -- I
THINK YOU KNOW AS FAR AS YOUR
CONCERNED DOES THIS HAPPEN AGAIN
I THINK WHAT WE'RE STRIVING TO
DO IS RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE TO
DO MORE TESTING WHEN WE MAKE
CHANGES TO THE SYSTEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE CATCHING.
SOME OF THE CODING ISSUES THAT --
FRANKLY STAFF WHO WERE OF ALL
THE CODING HAVE RETIRED OR NOT
PART OF THE STAFF ANYMORE --
AND DO WE HAVE THROUGH THE TEN
CHOOSE AS THAT.
BUT THAT'S REALLY PART O THE
OVERALL TECHNOLOGY
TRANSFORMATION THAT WE HAVE TO
UNDERTAKE --
YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL RELYING ON
KOBOL CODES IN THE SUMMER CODES
IT'S A VERY OLD AND DATED SYSTEM.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
TRANSFORMING THE DMV SYSTEM SO
IT CAN BE MORE AGILE TO RESPOND
TO THE NEEDS OF THE DMV.
I WAS THE ENVY MOVING TO THE
WHOLE FIRST CAL.
OUR SYSTEM AS WELL OR NO.
WHERE ARE WE ON THE SCHEDULE FOR
THE NETWORK WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
THE DEFERRED DEPARTMENT FROM THE
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE?
FROM A FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE
YOU'RE MOVING TOWARDS.
WE HAVE AN ORACLE ADMINISTRATIVE
FINANCIAL SYSTEM SOME WORMS CAL
STARS OR THEIR CUSTOMERS OKAY
BUT I JUST THE ONE MORE QUESTION
ON A DIFFERENT ASPECT THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP YOUR TESTIMONY THE
THE WELLNESS PROGRAM AD THE
EMPLOYEES OF TURN UNDERSTAND.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CULTURE
DMV.
YOU KNOW OUR WE HAVE A HUGE
WORKLOAD BEFORE US WE SEE THAT
COMING THERE'S BEEN ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED ALONG THE
WAY WE HAVE A STRIKE TEAM NOW --
YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
WE SAY WE GRANTED ADDITIONAL
JUST FOR ARGUMENT'S SAKE WE
GRANT AN ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION
IN THE BUDGET BUT YOU KNOW DO WE
HAVE WORKERS THAT ARE.
WANTING TO DO THIS AND TACKLE
THIS OR IS THERE A SENSE OF
FEELING OVERWORKED AND IT'S
THAT'S GOING TO BE ANOTHER
BARRIER FOR US GETTING ALL THIS
WERE COMPLETED.
A TREMENDOUS AND A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT CULTURE DMV IN TERMS OF
THE DIFFERENT OFFICES AND AND
THE TASK AHEAD OF US.
SO I CAN ONLY COMMENT ON MY
OBSERVATIONS THE LAST SIX WEEKS
BUT WHAT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU
IS MY IMPRESSION OF THE LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION THE
DMV EMPLOYEES IT'S IT REALLY IS
AMAZING AND IMPRESSIVE BECAUSE
EVEN UNDER DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SOMETIMES VERY
CRITICAL.
REVIEWS OF THE DMV THESE FOLKS
COME TO WORK EVERY DAY REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE PURPOSE OF THEIR
JOB AND WANTING TO SERVE THEIR
CUSTOMERS OF THE VERY BEST
LEVELS THAT THEY CAN.
I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US
TO GIVEN THE WORK ENVIRONMENT
AND THE TOOLS SO THEY CAN
SUCCESSFULLY PERFORM THAT JOB
BECAUSE THEIR HEART IS THERE.
IT'S GIVING THEM I THINK THE
SKILLS AND THE CAPABILITY TO
DELIVER ON THAT MISSION.
BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
WAYS TO COME --
AND REALLY CELEBRATE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS BUT ALSO REALLY
MAKE SURE WE'RE WORKING TO
IMPROVE HOW WE SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS AND AS I SAID EARLIER
IT'S REALLY ABOUT BUILDING THAT
FUTURE DMV THAT BETTER SERVES
OUR CHILDREN BECAUSE IT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
BUT I WANTED THE DMV STAFF TO
GET EXCITED ABOUT THAT FUTURE
VISION AND LAYING THAT OUT IS
REALLY CREATED KIND OF A RALLY
CRY TO SAY HOW CAN WE MAKE THIS
HAPPEN HOW CAN WE BE PART OF A
AND IF I CAN ADD TO THAT.
IS WHILE.
TALKING TRACK FIELD OFFICE STAFF
DAILY TO SEE THEIR ENTHUSIASM IN
THE SUMMERTIME IS THAT A TOUGH
TIME FOR OUR EMPLOYEES.
HE GREW THROUGH THAT AND THEY
HAVE A DEDICATED HEART AND SOUL
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY DON'T LIKE LONG WAIT LINES
JUST AS MUCH AS OUR CUSTOMERS
DON'T LIKE IT FROM A FROM A
STANCE WHEN THEY'RE SEEING THAT.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO REALLY AND SO PART OF
THE CHANGE AND PART OF THE
PROCESS AND THEY WELCOME THE
SUPPORT.
OF OUR NEW AND AT G. DIRECTOR AS
WELL AS THE STRAIGHT TEAM AND
THE PUBLIC AS WELL.
AND AND THEY'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE CHALLENGE AND I'M
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE EFFORTS
THAT THEY PUT FORTH THUS FAR.
AND I'M IS ENGAGING THEM AND
WE'RE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THEM
AND COMMUNICATE [inaudible]
GALGIANI --
I JUST WANTED TO CALL SOMETHING
TO YOUR ATTENTION AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES ATTENTION ALSO WE'RE
GETTING CALLS IN MY DISTRICT
OFFICE THAT --
FOR MEMBERS OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THEIR BIRTH
CERTIFICATE WHEN THEY GO TO GET
REAL ID.
AND THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE MOST
TIMES WILL INCLUDE THEIR LAST
NAME IS THEIR MOTHER'S LAST NAME
AND THEN THE FATHER'S LAST NAME.
AND THEN WHEN THEY PROVIDE OTHER
DOCUMENTATION IT'S NOT MATCHING
AND A SOME WONDERING IF IF YOU
RECALL EXPERIENCING THAT AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING TO DO.
TOO HELP THAT PROCESS ALONG.
I HAVEN'T I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
DIRECTLY OR HEARD OF THAT
DIRECTLY FROM OUR STAFF I CAN
EE WHERE THAT WOULD BE A
CHALLENGE --
DEFINITELY I THINK WHAT WE CAN
DO IS GO BACK AND AND TOUCHES
FOR OUR STAFF AND FIND WAYS THAT
WE CAN COMMUNICATE THAT BETTER --
WHETHER IT'S ON THE INTERNET
WORKING WITH OUR STAFF.
I'M HAPPY TO TO SPEAK WITH YOU
OR YOUR STAFF AND HOW WE CAN
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
IT'S A COMMON THING THAT HAPPENS
[inaudible]
YES.
OF ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THIS ORDER QUESTIONS.
WE SHOULD DO.
BEEN HERE WILL HAVE THE NEXT TO
LAST.
ANALYSTS TO COME FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I NEEDED A NEW LEE IS THE
PRINCIPAL FISCAL POLICY ANALYST.
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND SHE IS GOING TO
PRESENT THE REPORT TO US SO
WELCOME.
THE NEED A AND YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR.
THAT AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING US ON THE
SERGEANTS ARE CURRENTLY PASSING
OUT A HANDOUT THAT WILL BE USING --
TO GUIDE OUR COMMENTS TODAY WILL
REALLY BE FOCUSING ON KIND OF
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND ISSUES ON
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
KEEP IN MIND AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD --
WE'RE GONNA --
ON CERTAIN AREAS THAT HAVE ALL
GET OVER THAT BECAUSE YOU'VE
HEARD OF IT AT LENGTH IF YOU
HAVE COMMENTS.
YES.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE ONE OF
YOUR HAND OUT WE'RE GOING TO
SKIP OVER THIS PAGE THIS
GENERALLY PROVIDES.
INFORMATION ON REAL ID
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE IMPACT ON
DMV OPERATIONS.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OF YOUR
HAND OUT THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF A DISCUSSION ABOUT FUNDING
THAT'S PROVIDED SO FAR AND I
THINK THIS THIS PAGE I'LL GO
INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE DEPTH ON
AND SO --
GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE
WORKLOAD THE STATE DID PROVIDE
LIMITED TERM FUNDING FOR TWO
YEARS AND SPECIFICALLY IT WAS
TWENTY THREE MILLION FROM THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT TO SUPPORT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
POSITIONS AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND FORTY SIX POINT SIX MILLION
TO SUPPORT FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY POSITIONS.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ON TOP OF THAT THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
INCLUDED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT PROVIDED DMV NO SOONER
THAN THIRTY DAYS NOTIFICATION TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
AND THE TWO REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED --
UNDER THAT AUTHORITY ONE HAS
BEEN APPROVED AND ONE IS STILL
PENDING.
THE ONE THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED
WITH THE SUBMITTED AND APPROVED
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IT WAS FOR SIXTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS. TO
SUPPORT TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
POSITIONS SO IN TOTAL THAT
BRINGS THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ALLOCATION TO DMB TO SIXTY THREE
POINT TWO MILLION TO SUPPORT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
POSITIONS.
THE SECOND AMOUNT WHICH IS
PENDING --
WAS SUBMITTED IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND IN THAT
REQUEST THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE INDICATES THAT IT
INTENDS TO PROVIDE DMV WITH AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
NO SOONER THAN APRIL THIRTIETH.
EIGHTEEN AND THE DMV INDICATED
THAT THIS FUNDING WOULD BE USED
TO SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY POSITIONS AS
WELL AS TO MAINTAIN ALL OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'VE
IMPLEMENTED TO DATE TO BRING THE
WAIT TIMES DOWN.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE.
WHEN WAS THAT SUBMITTED?
THE THE FORTY POINT FOUR MILLION
WAS SUBMITTED IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SO IT'S STILL
OUTSTANDING NOW [inaudible]
GOOD.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE OF
YOUR HAND OUT THIS PROVIDES AN
OVERVIEW OF THE VARIOUS --
COMPONENTS RELATED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET THAT IMPACTS THE DMV.
SO THE FIRST AS THE DEPARTMENT
REFERENCED THERE IS A PLACE
HOLDER BUDGET REQUEST FOR SIXTY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION TO
SUPPORT SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
POSITIONS WHICH IS THE AMOUNT
THAT WE'VE PROVIDED SO FAR.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
HOWEVER THEY'VE CLEARLY
INDICATED THAT THIS REQUEST WILL
BE UPDATED AS DMV'S OPERATIONS
AND PROCESSES ARE EVALUATED.
AND THERE THEY ARE LOOKING TO
HAVE TWO EVALUATIONS INFORM THAT
ONE IS THE DMB REINFECTION
STRIKING WHICH YOU HEARD ABOUT
THE FIRST PANEL.
BUT THEN THE OTHER ONE IS THE
PERFORMANCE AUDIT THAT'S BEING
CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
EVALUATION.
AND THAT WAS STARTED IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND IT'S EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED BY THE END OF MARCH.
THE FINAL --
THING THAT WE WOULD BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ACTUALLY
INCLUDES A NEW PROPOSAL FOR A
NEW OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION
WHICH WOULD BE HOUSED WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY.
AND THIS OFFICE IS REALLY TASKED
WITH --
REQUIREMENTS FOR A DIP AS FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO REASSESS THEIR
SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL TO LOOK
AT RE ENGINEERING CUSTOMER
SERVICE DELIVERY AND ALSO TO
LEVERAGE --
KIND OF DIGITAL INNOVATION
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND APPROPRIATE.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE CONSIDERING
AS PART OF ITS BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS.
AND THEY DID INDICATE THE DMB
WOULD BE ONE OF THE FIRST
DEPARTMENTS TO WORK WITH THE
OFFICE IF IT WAS APPROVED.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR OF
YOUR HAND OUT --
IN EVALUATING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS WE DID
IDENTIFIES THREE ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD.
AND SO THE FIRST IS THAT A
NUMBER OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT MAY BE FLAGGED IN THESE
HAVE VALUATIONS COULD GENERATE
LONG TERM SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT TO
THE STATE. TO THE EXTENT THAT
DMV OPERATES MORE EFFICIENTLY OR
IMPROVES ITS CUSTOMER SERVICES
HOWEVER SOME OF THESE CHANGES
MAY TAKE TIME TO IMPLEMENT AND
TIME TO ACTUALLY REALIZE ALL OF
THE BENEFIT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE MAY REALLY
WANT TO CONSIDER FOCUSING ON
CHANGES THAT CAN GENERATE MORE
IMMEDIATE IMPACT BECAUSE OF THE
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE
AND THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT MAY BE COMING IN.
WHICH WILL LIKELY MEAN THAT
DMV'S WORK A LEVELS ARE AT LEAST
SIMILAR IF NOT HIGHER AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER THEIR HEART.
YES FOR MONTHS PLEASE I WAS
TRYING TO GET THAT NUMBER.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE
HIGHER.
YES AND SO AN EXAMPLE THAT WE
WOULD GIVE HERE IS THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT ADDITIONAL OR
IMPROVED OUTREACH EFFORTS COULD
REALLY IMPROVE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING INTO THE
FIELD OFFICES WITH ALL OF THEIR
PAPERWORK.
COMPLETED ALL NECESSARY
PAPERWORK COMING IN WITH THEM
AND I WOULD REALLY REDUCE THE
OVERALL TRANSACTION TIME PER
INDIVIDUAL.
THE SECOND ISSUE OF THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER IS
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE DMV REINVENTION
STRIKE TEAM TO REPORT IN THE
SPRING AT HEARINGS.
ON ALL OF THE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES AND CHANGES THAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED STATE AND
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO EVALUATE AND EXAMINE ALL OF
THEM NOT JUST THE ONES THAT HAVE
BEEN SELECTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUSION IN.
THE UPDATED BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
THE LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER
WHICH OF THESE --
OR OTHERS IT WOULD LIKE TO
INCLUDE THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT GIVING THE PENDING
INSOLVENCY OF THE MOTOR EHICLE
COUNT WHICH SUPPORTS BOTH DMV AS
WELL AS A CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
AND FINALLY REGARDLESS OF
HOWEVER MUCH MONEY IS PROVIDED --
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT IT'S
INTERESTED IN AND SO FOR EXAMPLE.
I AM I REFERENCE THE PENDING.
FORTY REQUEST THAT'S OUTSTANDING
WHEN THAT REQUEST CAME IN IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DMV INDICATED THAT A PORTION OF
THE FUNDING THAT THEY WERE
REQUESTING HAD ALREADY BEEN
SPENT.
AND SO THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER WHETHER DIRECTING
THE DEPARTMENT TO ACTUALLY SEEK
SPENDING OR INCREASING COSTS OF
THE LEGISLATURE CAN DETERMINE
THE REASONS FOR THOSE COSTS
INCREASE AND AND WHAT ACTIONS IF
ANY.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
TAKE MOVING FORWARD.
AND SO WITHOUT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
COMMENTS WERE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS WHAT WOULD BE THE
NORMAL PROCESS FOR THEM TO
REQUEST A BUDGET [inaudible]
OF ADDITION.
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW THEY START
SPEND THE MONEY AND THEN THEY
COME IN AFTERWARDS AND ASKED FOR
IT.
OF WHAT WOULD BE THE NORMAL
PROCEDURE.
SO THERE ARE --
SIDE THERE'S LANGUAGE IN TOWARDS
THE BACK OF THE BUDGET BILL
WHICH WE CALL --
CONTROL SECTIONS AND SO THERE'S
A SECTION LETTER PROCESS. FOR
WHICH REQUESTS CAN BE SUBMITTED
USUALLY --
DEPARTMENTS MAY SAY THERE'S AN
UNANTICIPATED EXPENSES ETCETERA --
THE LEGISLATURE CAN ALSO BUILD
IN LANGUAGE AS PART OF THE
BUDGET AND SO THE TO REQUEST
THAT I TALKED ABOUT ARE ACTUALLY
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
BUILT IN AS PART OF DMV'S
BUDGETARY ALLOCATION THE FOR THE
RULES THIS TIME OR WAS IT --
GRAY LINE.
WAS THE RULES FAULT.
BUDGET RULES.
SO I'VE THAT SO IN TERMS OF THE
FIRST ONE THE SIXTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION THAT --
ONE KIND OF WENT THROUGH THE
ROUTINE PROCESS AND IT WAS
APPROVED THERE WERE SOME
CONCERNS --
THAT WERE RAISED TO JUST IN
TERMS OF JUST FORWARD WHAT
ACTIONS WERE BEING TAKEN --
OVERSIGHT ABOUT WAIT TIMES
EXCITE OR A ON THE SECOND ONE
IT'S A IT'S A MUCH LARGER
REQUEST IT'S FORTY POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS --
I THINK THAT THERE'S LESS
CONCERNED ABOUT PROCESS --
IN TERMS OF THE INFORMATION
THAT'S PROVIDED I THINK THERE IS
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF CONCERN AS
WE INDICATED FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO THINK MOVING FORWARD.
ABOUT WHAT STAGE IS APPROPRIATE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT THOSE WHO
COME FORWARD OR RELIEVE THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS SO WHEN
THEY SUBMITTED THE REQUEST THAT
WAS THE ONE WHERE A PORTION OF
IT THEY HAD ALREADY SPENT THE
DOLLARS TO SO.
I WOULD SAY APPROXIMATELY HALF
OF IT HAD BEEN SPENT IN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS SPENT ABOUT
TWENTY MILLION A LITTLE BIT LESS
THAN THAT YEAH.
BUT IT HASN'T BEEN APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE.
I IT IS GAS SO THAT THE DATE IS
APRIL THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IN WHICH ACTION WE NEED
TO BE TAKEN AS THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ANOTHER ONE ANTICIPATED IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR.
THAT IS A QUESTION THAT'S
PROBABLY BETTER DIRECTED TO THE
DEPARTMENTS THEY CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
YEAH BECAUSE IT WOULD BE THEIR
INTENTION IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY PLAN ON SUBMITTING
WHILE WORKING WITH THE PART IN A
FINANCED OR TO GET A HANDLE ON
THIS.
YOU KNOW EVERY THREE MONTHS
ASKING FOR MONEY THING THAT'S
GOING ON HERE SO SO.
AND HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD BE THAT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO IDENTIFY.
AND THEN WHAT IS THE OVER YOU
KNOW LIKE OVERALL BUDGET REQUEST
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A CLEARER
PICTURE ON THE SUBJECT.
ABOUT WHAT THE MONEY SITUATION
AS WE NEED TO HAVE A PROCESS
IT'S PRETTY.
CLEAR FOR US --
WE DON'T WANT TO BE THE LAST TO
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO PUT IT THAT
WAY.
YES I AM AS PART OF OUR BUDGET
WORKLOAD APRIL AND MAY WHICH
WHICH YOU'RE QUITE FAMILIAR WITH.
WE WILL EVALUATE THE UPDATED
PROPOSAL THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CLEARLY INDICATED THERE'S AN
UPDATED PROPOSAL COMING.
AND SO WE WOULD EVALUATE THAT
ALONG WITH WHAT CHANGES --
THE DEPARTMENT OR THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS IN MIND THAT
A COMPANIES THAT REQUEST YOU
THINK THAT THE THAT THE CURRENT
STATUS OF DONE SO FAR.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
THE REAL ID APPLICATIONS.
ARE BY THE DEADLINE.
IN THE UPDATED REQUESTS TO WE
WOULD LOOK AT THEIR FORECASTING
METHODOLOGY I THINK FROM THE
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY THEY ARE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN REVISITING THAT --
AND SO WE WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A DISCUSSION
WITH THEM AND SO AT THAT POINT
WE WOULD BE.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO BETTER
ADVISE YOU.
IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCES IWOULD READ THE
REASON WHY I'M ASKING --
IS THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE --
SUCH A LARGE GAP.
THAT IT MAY BE A VERY COSTLY
REQUEST.
AND I THINK HAVING A SURPRISE
LAKE -- TWO
WEEKS BEFORE I APPROVAL OF A
HUNDRED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WOULD NOT BE A VERY NICE THING
TO DO THAT THE LEGISLATURE I
THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE.
SOME UNDERSTANDING OF THE SCOPE
AND MAGNITUDE.
OF WHAT THE REQUEST MIGHT BE --
I TRIED TO GET THE INFORMATION --
WILL TRY TO GET IT MORE BUT I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOUR OPINION
AS WHAT SCOPE AND MAGNITUDE YOU
THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THERE'S
REALLY TWO LEVERS THAT YOU POLL --
THERE IS THE THE THE SALARY AND
EMPLOYEES IN TERMS OF HERE'S THE
WORKLOAD WE'RE NOT CHANGING
ANYTHING ELSE THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE OPERATING --
HERE'S A LEVEL OF RESOURCES THAT
WILL BE NEEDED --
I THINK FROM THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THERE'S CLEAR RECOGNITION
THAT THE SECOND LEVER WHICH
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED WHICH IS
THIS ISSUE OF EFFICIENCY IS AN
OPERATIONAL CHANGES.
AND THAT WILL LIKELY NEED ON
THAT OTHER SIDE IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYEES AND STAFF I THINK
THERE ARE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
ARE IN PROGRESS WE'VE HEARD OF
THINGS THAT THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED --
ALL OF WHICH HAVE THE POTENTIAL --
BUT REALLY THAT KIND OF LEADS TO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
POTENTIALLY CONSIDER WHICH IS.
WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE THE
CHANGES WHAT CHANGES --
HOW WILL HAVE KIND OF IMMEDIATE
IMPACT BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE THIS
LOOMING DEADLINE OF OCTOBER?
TWENTY TWENTY AND WHAT WERE YOU
KNOW IN THE PROCESS OF FIGURING
OUT THE EXACTION NUMBERS WE DO
KNOW THAT GIVEN TO DATE.
WHETHER IT'S TWO POINT FIVE OR
THREE MILLION INDIVIDUALS WHO
COME FORWARD YOU'RE LIKELY TO BE
A NUMBER.
AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL COME FORTH
BEYOND YOU JUST THE NORMAL CYCLE
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE DOING
RENEWALS THE REASON I'M ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS IS YOU.
I THINK WHICH IS FOCUS ON THE
MEDIA TRY.
TO DEAL WITH --
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S GOING TO BE
A STEADY.
NUMBER OR SOMETHING IS GONNA
SEARCH AT THE AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT WHAT THE PROBABILITY THAT
WILL.
BE HAPPENING.
UP TO OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE
GONNA.
WANT TO HAVE THE REAL ID'S.
BUT THEN FIND THAT --
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
AT THE END BECAUSE OF A JUST --
BREAK DOWN BECAUSE OF THE HUGE
SURGE THAT TAKES PLACE.
THAT'S BY.
pTHINK THAT --
WE WANT.
TO TRY THE PLAN --
APPROPRIATELY AND DO WITH THAT --
BY BOTH MONEY SOLUTION WE HAVE
TO HAVE AN EFFICIENCY SOLUTION.
FOR THAT AND OF I THINK.
WE NEED YOUR HELP IN IDENTIFYING
THE THE SOLUTIONS --
TO BE TARGETED.
THE COULD SAVE US THE MOST MONEY
AND TIME FOR THE PROCESSING AND
SO FORTH.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT --
BUT ALSO ON A LONG TERM BASIS SO.
YOU HAVE REACHED LEAST A REPORT
OR OR ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE FUND
CORRECT.
CAN YOU GIVE US AN IDEA A REPORT
JUST A BRIEF SUMMARY OF WHAT THE
REPORT SAID.
SHORT OF MORE OF A MEDIUM TERM.
SURE -- SO
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
RECEIVES A VARIETY OF FEES
INCLUDING --
SOME OF THE FEES THAT ARE
CHARGED BY DMV SO FOR EXAMPLE
YOUR VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEE --
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE WE ACCEPT
OUR A AND SO THERE HAVE BEEN
OPERATIONAL SHORTFALLS IN RECENT
YEARS AND KIND OF LOOKING
TOWARDS THE NEXT FEW YEARS --
IT'S PROJECTED TO BECOME
POTENTIAL SO --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED A
FEW ACTIONS TO HELP ADDRESS THAT
INSOLVENCY PROFOUNDLY RELATED --
TO DELAYING FOR EXAMPLE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS ETCETERA.
INS AND IN OUR REPORT WE DID
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
SOME ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION FOR THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO ADDRESS THAT INSOLVENCY.
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE THINGS
INCLUDE --
THERE'S CURRENTLY AT A LOAN THAT
THAT NEEDS TO BE REPAIRED
RELATED TO A SUPPLEMENTAL PETE.
IT'S NOT REALLY LAUNCH --
IT'S IT'S A PAYMENT SCHEDULE
REPAYMENT SCHEDULE RELATED TO A
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
PLAN THAT WAS MADE AND IT'S THE
REPAYMENT HAS TO COME FROM THE
VARIOUS SPECIAL FUNDS AND S ONE
SOLUTION IS TO KIND OF DELAY OR
CHANGE.
ON THAT SCHEDULE FOR THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT.
THE OTHER ONE IS TO POTENTIALLY
ELIMINATE THIS GENERAL FUND
TRANSFER THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
MADE FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT INTEREST ENDING THAT
TRANSFER.
ANOTHER ONE IS A TRANSFER FUNDS.
IT'S A TRANSFER FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT TO THE GENERAL
FUND ONE WAS.
WITH THE USE OF FOR WELL WHEN
IT'S THAT THEY GIVE A PURPOSE
SERVICES GENERALLY JUST DONE
IT'S IT'S AVAILABLE ON THE
GENERAL FUND.
FOR LEGISLATIVE PURPOSES OKAY MY
COLLEAGUE.
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS LIKE WAS
THERE.
SOMEBODY SOMEBODY CAME UP AND
SAID WHAT WE WANT TO TRANSFER --
THIS MONEY AND THEN SOMEBODY
ASKED THE QUESTION WHY OKAY LOW
THAT'S THE IN.
QUESTION I WOULD HAVE WELL WHY
WAS IT TRANSFER.
THERE WAS A REASON.
OKAY WE GOT ANOTHER HEALTHCARE
ANTHONY SYMBOL FROM THE LA OKAY
HE STARTED BEGINNING IN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE TEN AND IT REALLY
WAS SORT OF A ONE TIME THE FIRST
YEAR.
BECAUSE THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION AT THE TIME IN THESE
ARE.
REVENUES THAT ARE RESTRICTED BY
THE CONSTITUTION UNLIKE THE
REGISTRATION FEES TWITTER FOR
WHEN YOU'RE THERE WITH A
DIFFERENT ANOTHER ONE TIME BASIS
BUT IDEA WAS IT WAS POSSIBLY
TEMPORARY.
BUT AFTER A WHILE WE JUST THAT
ARE DOING ON ONGOING BY BUDGET
AXES TO DO THIS FOR YOU HOW THE
FUNDS REMAIN IN THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
THAT WITHOUT HELP THE SOLVENCY
ISSUE.
IT WILL COMPLETELY SOBER BUT IT
WILL HELP.
OKAY SO SO IF THERE'S A FURTHER
BUDGET REQUEST OTHER THAN THIS.
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE COMING THIS
FISCAL YEAR MAYBE AND THEN --
THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR.
WITH THOSE --
WITH THAT COME OUT OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE FINER HOW WOULD THAT
WITH THOSE --
REQUEST BEFORE CORRECT --
LIKE --
MISLI MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES HAVE A PLACE HOLDER
FOR THE WRITING WAIT TIMES THE
EXTENT ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
SPEND MORE THAN THAT LEVEL.
THAT WILL COME FROM IN VA.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE SECRETARY
ABOUT DIFFERENT IDEAS HAVING
MORE KIOSK HAVING MORE STAFF
THAT'S ALL GOING TO COME FROM
BECAUSE OF THE MV UNLESS YOU
FIND SOME OF THE FUND SOURCE?
I WOULD ALSO NOT EVEN THE IDEA
OF USING CREDIT CARD
TRANSACTIONS CURRENTLY WHEN WE
DO WHEN --
PORT CERVICAL ONLINE WITH A
CREDIT CARD AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE THAT PRACTICE AND ALLOW
CREDIT CARD TRANSACTIONS AND
FILLED OFFICE.
IN THE STATE PICKED UP THE
TRANSACTION BECAUSE THAT'S
ANOTHER HIT TO THEM VIA TO THE
EXTENT IT'S PAID FOR FROM THE
MPA.
JUST JUST --
MY FILL ALL PHILOSOPHICAL
APPROACH OF FOCUSING THE DMV ON
CORE SERVICES ONLY.
AND GETTING RID OF SOME OF THE
STUFF LIKE I SAID THE PENAL CODE
IN MAYBE LOOKING AT OTHER WAYS
OF REDUCING SOME OF THOSE OTHER
THINGS THAT THE DMV DOES. FOR
OTHER DEPARTMENTS SOCIAL SERVICE
SOMEBODY SAID I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT IS BUT WE HEARD THAT TODAY --
THE QUESTION WOULD BE CAN YOU.
IN YOUR ANALYSIS BEFORE WEEKS
RECEIVE THESE REQUESTS FOR
BUDGET --
GIVE US A PROJECTION OF HOW
THEY'RE GOING.
TO MEET THE DEADLINE FOR THE
REAL ID AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE MOTOR VEHICLE FUND AFTER
THAT.
IS THERE ARE GOING TO BE.
MORE THE THE THE THE THEY IMPLY
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME PEOPLE
THAT WILL APPLY FOR THIS MONEY
AFTER.
THE DEADLINE FOR THE DMV IS THAT
MEAN THAT THEY'RE GOING.
TO CONTINUE TO DRAW DOWN THE
MOTOR VEHICLE FUND FOR THE REAL
LIKE THE COST --
SO THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I WANT
A NEED SOME.
CLARIFICATION ON IN TERMS OF
THIS THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
WHEN THE ADMINISTRATION PRESENTS
ITS UPDATED PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES?
WE WILL KIND OF EVALUATE THE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS SO AS
YOU'RE SAYING THE ESTIMATES
QUESTIONS FOR THE YES SO THE
ESTIMATES OF THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE COMING IN EXETER AT AN AS
PART OF THAT --
AND AS WELL AS ANY OTHER SPRING
BUDGET REQUEST THAT MAY COME
FORWARD --
WE WOULD KIND OF SEE WHAT THAT
IMPACT WAS ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT LOOK AT THAT FINE
CONDITION AND SO WE WOULD
EVALUATE FOLLOW.
YOU VALUE WITH THE ANY.
OF THE POTENTIAL FISH THAT'S
YEAH AND AND THE MOTOR VEHICLE
FUND MONEY OF THAT THAT THAT'S
AND THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE TO
BALANCE THE FOR WE'RE GOING AND
DEFAULT ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE
FUND WE HAVE TO KIND OF WE'RE
YOU KNOW SAVE SOME MONEY
SOMEWHERE.
SO EVENTULLY FOR THOSE THAT
THINGS WILL LOOK AT ALSO THING
FROM THE LECTURES OVERSIGHT WHEN
THEY MINISTRY SINCE COME FOR
WITH ANY EFFICIENCIES WHETHER
IT'S ENCOURAGING MORE PREFERRED
ONLINE.
I SHOULD ASK THEM HOW IS THAT
GOING TO HOUSE A SECOND SAVE
MONEY WITHOUT HAVING SOME TO GO
IN THE FIELD OFFICE PART OF
THEIR TRANSACTION IS GOING TO BE
LESS WORK LOW SO WHAT IS THAT
FREE UP.
CAN ONLY DO ONE LOOK AT THE COST
OF WHAT THEY WANT TO DO BUT ALSO
WHAT ARE THE SAVINGS THEY EXPECT
TO GENERATE THAT COULD BE.
REDIRECTED TO OTHER THINGS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO REGISTER CARVE A
YEAR THAT'S ANOTHER ONE I MEAN
THE THE OTHER OTHER IDEAS FOR
THE WE SHOULD HAVE LIKE --
AN EVALUATION OF ALL THOSE IDEAS --
AND IF WE PUSH THOSE EFFICIENCY
IDEAS OFTEN.
I THINK IT IT CREATES A
PROBABILITY THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A SURGE THAT WILL ALL BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH.
THAT'S THAT'S MY OPINION.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT
NOW.
COME UP WITH EFFICIENCIES NOW
DOT WAIT GET IT GOING.
IT'S OF THESE IDEAS MOVING ALONG
I HOPE THE STRIKE FORCE --
IS ABLE.
TO A TAKE THE SENSE OF URGENCY.
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE FUND'S
SOLVENCY AND THE MEETING THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO CREATE --
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ALL THEIR REAL
ID -- DONE
BY THE DEADLINE.
AS MUCH AS WE CAN --
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER SENATORS
QUESTIONS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S --
OKAY --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
ARE WE HAVE PUBLIC LOCAL TAKE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE.
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
SIR DO YOU HAVE A OF YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE SIR YOU CAN YOU CAN
USE THE MICROPHONE.
RIGHT OVER THERE NEXT TO YOU YOU
CAN.
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE SIR.
WE'RE I UNDERSTAND OKAY GO
THROUGH PLEASE IN --
THE ONLY A ONE MINUTE THOUGH BUT
CDM DMV IN THE SEVENTIES
HORRIBLE'S.
STAFF VERY RUDE THE HAVES TO
SERVE TIME SIR LISTEN.
MAKE CAN YOU JUST TELL US WHO
YOU ARE THAT ARE I AM A MEDICAL
DOCTOR IN NEW YORK CITY LA IN
MEXICO AND AND WHAT'S YOUR NAME
SIR --
GREGORY CLAVIN OVERAGE THANK YOU
GREGORY --
IF YOU MAKE DMV PRIVATE.
ID THREE OR FOUR PRIVATE
COMPANIES TAKEOVER DMV --
THEY CAN COMPETE FOR CUSTOMERS
AND WAIT TIME WILL DECREASE --
SWEEPING DMV A PRIVATE RESEARCH
ORGANIZATIONS GET THE GOVERNMENT
OUT OF DMV THE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACIES.
ARE ALWAYS AWKWARD IN AN
EFFICIENT.
INEFFICIENT IF THE BARRIERS ARE
ONLINE OR TAKEN DOWN YU CAN
MONITOR THE PRIVATE COMPANIES
MAKE IT TRANSPARENT --
NUMBER --
SIX EVERYBODY'S GONNA HAPPEN --
PHONE THESE DAYS RIGHT CAN'T YOU
DO A DMV APPLICATION.
ON AN APP.
UGH SPENCER RECESSES HITS A SAYS
HERE YOU GUYS SAY EXPAND
SERVICES INTO SATURDAY WHEN ON
EXPANSION IS SUNDAY SERVICE.
WHO NEED JOBS --
GIVEN JOBS ON SUNDAY.
LET'S SEE A WOUNDED WARRIORS
HOUNDS ME EVERY MONTH FOR BAKING
FOR MONEY CAN THEY BE THERE CAN
YOU PUT THEIR EFFICIENT
NONPROFIT.
COMPANY TO PARLAY TAKEOVER DMV
CRUISES DOWN EUROPEAN RIVERS ARE
HOUNDING ME TWO TIMES A MONTH TO
TAKE A CRUISE THEY COULD
[inaudible]
TAKE OVER.
DMV IN IN PART.
ARE THE GENTLEMAN OVER HERE.
MIKE MORALLY I THINK IT IS
MORRELL --
MOROSE OR HE RAISED TO COMMENT
AND I MADE ME THINK.
SOCIAL SECURITY CARD DMV
PASSPORT --
WHAT JUST ONE ID FOR WORLDWIDE
YOU CAN PUT A CHIP UNDER THE
SKIN?
NOW HE MADE COMMENTS MIKE
MORRELL MIGHT BE ON THE SERVER
PAGE.
SIR CAN YOU WRAP IT UP PLEASE --
BUT HIS LAST SENTENCE --
HE SAID TO RESPOND TO HIM HE
LEFT UP IN YOUR GREEDY HIS
WRISTS HIS QUESTION THE FIRST
SPEAKER WE KNOW WHAT A PSYCH
VISITING DMV THESE DAYS.
JUST LOSE YOUR WALLET OR PRETEND
TO LOSE YOUR WALLET AND GOING TO
TRY TO GET NEW ID YOU WILL SEE
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO DEAL WITH
THE WAIT TIME.
OKAY SIR THANK YOU.
HEY SIR IF YOU HAVE IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING IN WRITING --
YOU WANNA PULL TOGETHER AND GIVE
IT TO US --
YOU YOU.
YEAH IF YOU LIKE YEAH SURE LOANS
I'D I'D READ IF YOU DID THAT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY
IS THERE ANY OTHER TESTIMONY
HERE --
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR THE
SHARING AND WERE ADJOURNED THE
TRANSFER THIS COMMITTEES ADDRESS